learn all the basics of structured query
language in this comprehensive SQL
course you will build out real database
tables and practice querying them in
flexible ways as a back-end web
developer would in the production
setting Lane Wagner created this course
Lane is an experienced software engineer
and creator of boot.dev so let's get
started as a web developer you might
think that you need to know JavaScript
and Python and go and typescript but I'm
actually here to tell you that what you
really need to know is SQL or SQL see no
matter what programming language you end
up using day to day as a developer it's
very likely that you'll actually be
using SQL alongside that programming
language in your Web projects stick
around and in just a few more minutes
I'll explain why SQL can actually be a
game changer for your career I'm Lane
the founder of boot.dev and the host of
the back end banter podcast and I've
been writing SQL for about 10 years now
I've spent over a year designing this
course and updating the material and
I've actually already taught thousands
of students with this stuff and all of
their feedback has actually gone back
into the course improving it over time
so what you're about to watch is
actually some really battle tested
material during this course we'll be
learning all the foundational SQL skills
that you need but will be focused on the
stuff that's most important for web
development the best part is that we'll
be Hands-On keyboard building out a real
world database layer for an actual web
application it's actually a PayPal clone
that I'm calling cash pal this next part
is very important do not please do not
binge watch this video look tutorial
hell is a real place it's a place you're
gonna find yourself if you don't write
your own code so please code with me so
head over to boot.dev right now grab a
free account and that's where you can
actually follow along with every
exercise right in your browser
alternatively if you don't want to
create a boot.dev account I've also
linked all of the raw text files down in
the description below there's a GitHub
link now be aware this SQL course is
actually just one part of a full
back-end developer career path over on
boot.dev if you're interested in going
from xero to hireable as a back-end
developer definitely go check that out
as well if you get stuck during this
course don't worry about it we've got
three resources that you can check out
the first is the boot.dev Discord the
second is the free code Camp Discord and
the third is the free codecamp forum all
of those places are great resources for
getting help they'll be linked down in
the description below lastly if you want
to connect with me personally there's
three places you can find me on Twitter
or X at wagslane you can go sign up on
boot.dev and I'll be in your email or
I'm also the host of the back end banter
podcast which you can find in any major
podcast player or just here on YouTube
with that out of the way let's talk
about SQL
as a back-end engineer one day I'm
sitting in my office of work and my boss
is staring kind of longingly out the
window and I walk over and he says look
at that guy look at that guy shoveling
manure oh this isn't fun that's what I
do that's what I do day to day as a
developer and I mean he was right as
developers we just kind of take data
from one place and shovel it into
another place where it's kind of moving
crap around and the best tool that we
have for moving crap around is SQL or
SQL say you're a developer working at
YouTube your job is to shovel data from
creators devices right so a video a
title a description a thumbnail shovel
that up into the cloud and store it in
some database and then your job is to
shovel that data back down to users
devices where they can watch the videos
and see the thumbnails SQL or structured
query language often also called SQL I
like to call it SQL easier to say fewer
syllables this is the language that we
use to communicate with most databases
the vast majority of databases use SQL
as a query language a protocol that we
use to communicate and get data in and
out of database servers things like
MySQL postgresql or SQL Lite a database
is just a piece of software that makes
it easy to store large amounts of data
in your computer's file system you could
kind of think about it as just a really
Advanced Microsoft Excel or an advanced
Google Sheets when you work with Google
Sheets or Excel you're probably moving
data around fairly manually right you're
pointing and clicking dragging and
dropping when you work with SQL and with
a database you automate all of that
right so you write code that automates
the creates the reads the updates and
the deletes within the database that's
why SQL is so cool and that's why as
backend developers SQL is critically
important let's hop right into the first
lesson and we'll start writing some SQL
so here on the right I have my kind of
starter SQL code for the lesson on the
left I've got my instructions and then
down here at the bottom I have the
ability to run and submit the code now
it's important to note that all
throughout this course we're going to be
writing SQL that's executed against the
cash pal database and cash pal is really
just a toy web application that's sort
of a clone of PayPal PayPal is an
application for sending money online and
cash pal is basically the same thing in
toy form right so you can imagine that
the data that's stored in cashpile's
database is things like users right who
are the people that use cashpow and then
transactions right every time one user
sends money to another user we need to
store that information in our database
so let's jump right into the assignment
it says I have provided a simple SQL
statement for you that retrieves some
records from a table however there isn't
a people table the table in our database
is called users fix the bug by changing
people to users within the select
statement so here we've got select star
from people
um it looks like there was just you know
mistake made so we're going to swap that
out for select star from users in fact
let me really quickly run it in its Old
State and just see what happens
SQL logic error no such table people
okay cool and then let's change it to
users run that code
perfect and I just want to call
attention to the fact that the output of
our little SQL statement here isn't
console output like you might get in a
programming language like python or go
instead we actually get a result set
that's kind of formulated as a table of
rows and columns so now let's kind of
break down the anatomy of the select
statement that we modified in the first
exercise it's important to note that
select statements are probably the most
common type of statement that you'll
write in SQL because select statements
are the equivalent of a read operation
right it's how we get data out of the
database let's take a look at this first
example right select ID from users in
this case we're selecting the ID column
from the user's table and all SQL
statements end in a semicolon so we're
saying give me all of the IDS
from the users table it's also worth
pointing out that keywords in SQL are
case insensitive generally speaking SQL
is case insensitive so this select
statement is all caps which is typically
the convention the convention would
normally also be for this from keyword
to be all caps but I just wanted to
demonstrate that it doesn't actually
matter it will work either way so we've
talked about how to select a single
field or a single column right select ID
from users I'm selecting multiple Fields
is also pretty easy we just separate
field names with a comma right so if we
want all of the IDS and the names from
the users table then we would select ID
comma name from users now in the last
assignment we actually just selected all
fields we didn't name explicitly which
fields from the table we wanted to get
back we said just give me all of the
columns that exist on the table right
and when you want to do that you just
use the star operator or the wildcard
operator instead of explicitly naming
every single field and separating with
comma so moving on to the assignment it
says the state of our cash pal users
table is as follows gives us this nice
little table so keep in mind this is the
data that's that's actually in the
database right and when we write a
select statement we're generally trying
to select some subset of that data we
generally don't want all of the data in
the database to come back from our query
we're just trying to get at something
specific right so the assignment goes on
it says it's very common to write
queries that only return specific
portions of data from a table our HR
team has requested a report asking for
all of the names and balances of all of
our users write a query that retrieves
all of the names and balances from the
users table so let's go ahead and do
that
start with a select keyword
and we're not going to do star because
we just want name
and balance we just want the name and
the balance columns right from and I
will capitalize uh to kind of adhere to
conventions uh from the users table
go ahead and run that so you can see all
we got back was names and balances if we
wanted for example the age as well then
we could add age here
right and we'd get an additional column
back in our result set but we don't need
H right the assignment didn't ask for
that so we'll go ahead and submit that
so many databases use SQL SQL is just a
query language right and lots of
different database Technologies out
there use SQL or allow us to write SQL
in order to interface with the database
right so postgres is a really popular
one it's one that I use in production
all the time SQL Lite is really popular
it's the one that we're using in this
course actually SQL Lite is uh what boot
Dev is running on the back ends to power
this whole interactive experience
um but but really that's all you need to
know is that SQL is a Common Language so
when you learn SQL you'll be able to use
basically any database that supports SQL
though it is worth mentioning that while
SQL is a Common Language sometimes
databases support different dialects of
SQL so you will see minor differences
right maybe SQL Lite only supports
certain data types whereas postgres
supports other data types so there are
little nuances but generally
when you pick up SQL is a skill it will
make it so that you're able to use all
these databases even if you do have to
look up little things that are different
from time to time so let's jump into
this assignment it says one way in which
sqlite is a bit different is that it
stores Boolean values as integers right
the integers zero and one so it's very
kind of raw binary in that way select
all the IDS names and is admin flags
from the users table okay
pretty straightforward so select
ID name is admin from users
go ahead and run that looks good to me
you may have heard that SQL isn't web
scale why didn't you use mongodb mongodb
is a web scale database just by not
using structured query language you can
make your database scale to billions and
billions of users
anyways that's not how it works let's
talk about the real differences between
SQL and nosql let's look at a few of the
more popular examples in both categories
so on the SQL side we've got postgres ql
one of my personal favorites for sure
um you've probably heard of MySQL
um SQL Lite
we've got SQL Server SQL Server that's
Microsoft's
uh you've probably heard of Oracle
and also throw in a mention of cockroach
cockroachdbe
okay so these are just a few examples
there's literally hundreds of SQL
databases out there but these are ones
that you you may have heard of
um nosql databases
got
mongodb you probably heard of redis
you may have heard of elastic elastic
search
uh Firebase Firebase is pretty popular
and we'll also mention Dynamo dynamodb
that's Amazon's so these are just some
examples of databases that fall into the
SQL and the no SQL categories now the
first thing you need to understand about
the difference between SQL and nosql
databases is that the SQL databases
tends to be much more similar I mean
they're in a group because they're all
SQL databases so right out of the gate
they have something in common whereas
the nosql databases all they have in
common is the fact that they don't use
SQL right they don't all use the same
query language right I'll SQL databases
use structured query language they have
a common language that we use to
interface with the databases nosql
databases do not all use the same query
language they just don't use SQL now SQL
databases also tend to be they tend to
be kind of General
purpose
now that's not always true right at the
end of the day a SQL database is just
any database that supports SQL right so
you could have a specialized database
but it just so happens that the most
popular SQL databases tend to sort of be
general purpose which means they're
often a great starting point for most
web applications or websites and right
out of the gate I'm going to go ahead
and call out an exception here in that
cockroachdb is kind of an outlier among
these databases in that it's a very
distributed database kind of built for
scale right so you add some complexity
to the database you get some scaling
benefits same with SQL Lite sqlite is
kind of purpose built for very small
applications where you embed your
database like directly within your
application so those two I'm going to
kind of just flag as
a little different not quite as general
purpose now no SQL databases on the
other hand tend to be specialized
specialized
right so usually no SQL databases are
built for a very specific purpose right
and again at flag an exception mongodb
tends to be a little bit more of a
general purpose database but for example
redis is often just used for caching
or kind of in-memory key value stores
right so it's very specifically built
for one use case a lot of times uh web
apps will use redis and a SQL database
elasticsearch as you could probably tell
is very often used for search
and used for aggregations
right so if you have for example a giant
search component on your site right like
the eBay search bar for example you
might use elasticsearch to make those
searches efficient Firebase is Google's
product it's kind of specifically good
at real time
real time
and mobile like like mobile apps
right and then dynamodb is is probably
actually similar to it's a little
bit more uh general purpose but it's
aws's kind of specific product for data
at scale now I've done a lot of hand
waving here but the thing that I really
want you to take away from this is that
at the end of the day an SQL database is
just any database that can be interacted
with using the programming language
structured query language SQL right and
any nosql database is a database that
just doesn't have that right it probably
has its own kind of proprietary or
specific query language that you'll use
to interact with it just like any
technology decision when you're deciding
which database to use for your project
you really need to kind of weigh the
pros and cons of the database against
your specific use case that said for
most simple web applications or websites
something like postgres is going to do
really well right it's a general purpose
database that can handle scale at a
decent level as your application scales
up and you understand more your specific
needs right maybe you need caching maybe
you need search you can look at
introducing other database Technologies
to your stack so as we spoke about
earlier the big difference between SQL
and nosql databases is just whether or
not the databases support the use of SQL
right and that's what this assignment is
talking about and it really I want to
reiterate the fact that no SQL databases
don't have all that much in common right
for example there's there's a bunch of
new SQL document databases and those
tend to have more in common with each
other right mongodb and dynamodb for
example are both kind of document stores
and and they're more similar than just
like the whole group of all nosql
databases right key value stores like
redis and memcache are quite similar but
they're not similar to again other nosql
databases like like manga they're kind
of in a class of their own if that makes
sense so the question for this
assignment is each nosql database tends
to use blank query languages and the
answers are the same or different and
I'm going to say different because
they're kind of all over the place the
next question on SQL versus nosql is
blank compatible databases tends to be
more similar in their functionality than
blank databases so nosql and SQL or SQL
no scale well I let's see what makes
sense here SQL compatible databases tend
to be more similar in their
functionality than nosql databases so
it's going to be that second one
next question is which type of database
always uses table structures right so
SQL organizes data into tables right
when we're writing our SQL queries
earlier we're doing select star from
users right the users Table stores data
SQL assumes the existence of tables that
we can select data from right nosql
databases don't always use that
terminology don't even always use that
way of grouping data right so it's just
SQL that always uses table structures
I really quickly want to just come pair
a few of the popular SQL databases that
are out there you may have heard of
postgres MySQL Microsoft SQL server
sqlite and there are a ton of others in
fact if you want to follow this link
here you can go look at really the all
of the at least relatively well-known
SQL databases that exist and there's
more than a hundred so let's quickly
just compare sqlite and postgres so
we're using sqlite in this course but I
do use postgres in later web development
courses on boot Dev I think they're both
great databases sqlite is sort of built
for the embedded use case so it's really
great when like resources are
constrained maybe you need a database on
like a mobile device or if you're
deploying say to the edge right maybe if
you're running a database say hundreds
of copies of your database on different
Edge servers distributed geographically
around the world SQL sqlite can be
really good for that it's really good at
it being embedded within your
application so there are great use cases
in production even for sqlite postgres
on the other hand is more of a monolith
a postgres acts as a server itself and
will typically be used for more
traditional web applications that need
to serve more users or at least operate
at a larger scale right so if you're
storing massive amounts of data in your
database postgres will be a better
option most likely than SQL light
postgres also just has many more
features than sqlite right so if you're
storing lots of data in a database and
you need to do lots of complex things
postgres is going to serve your needs a
little bit better and one of those
features is kind of exhaustive type
checking so sqlite is pretty
loosey-goosey with types right you can
specify Types on your columns but at the
end of the day sqlite will kind of just
let you put whatever you want anywhere
whereas postgres will enforce kind of
more strict static type checking to show
you what I mean let's jump down into the
assignment so it says let's look at how
sqlite does not enforce type checking
notice within the create table statement
name is defined as a text field right
okay so we've got this first statement
create table users it's got an ID field
that's an integer a name field that is
text and an age field that is an integer
next it's inserting two two records into
that table
ID name age values one John Doe and 21
right so id1 name John Doe h21 and then
also inserting a second record into the
table where ID is two name is Montgomery
Burns and age is 33 and then finally
there's a select star from users table
that runs so let's go ahead and just run
that code so you can see
see the output right got this users
table we've got some data in there
so it says run the code and take a look
at the results we did that on line three
change the text string Montgomery Burns
to the integer one and run the code
so this is what's kind of interesting
right we're no longer putting text
in the name field we're putting an
integer there
but it still works right sqlite just
like doesn't care whereas postgresp
would have actually thrown an error
um at us in this instance
so it says notice how even though we'd
find name as text sqlite allowed us to
use an integer like Python and
JavaScript SQL Lite has a loose type
system you can store anything anywhere
so to pass the assignment submit the
code in the altered state where the
record with id2
has a name of one
cool we'll just submit like this
so by now we're familiar with the idea
of a table in a database right a table
has columns and every new entry in the
table is a row in the table right each
row of course having multiple cells each
with a value for the associated column
right so for example a user's table
might have ID name date of birth as
columns and then every new user would
get their own Row in the table well now
let's look at the SQL statement that we
can use to create new tables Okay so
we've got the create table statement so
create table and then the name of the
table so in this example we're creating
an employees table and then we're
specifying a few different columns that
we want to create right an ID column
that's of type integer a name column of
type text an age column of type integer
and finally is manager which is a
Boolean in salary which is an integer um
this is kind of annoying to specify the
create table statement horizontally like
this so there's
um a little more uh well organized
syntax that we can use like this where
we kind of split it up onto new lines
with some nice indentation to make it a
little bit easier to read right but the
takeaway here is that name of the table
comes right after the create table
statement then we've got an open and a
closed parenthesis and inside we specify
all the fields and their types so let's
jump down into the assignment and write
some SQL
though the assignment says let's begin
building a table for the cashpile
database create the people table with
the following Fields all right so create
table
going to be called people
open parentheses the names of all the
fields we've got ID which is an integer
not a comma to separate between the
columns you'll notice that I'm using the
term column and field kind of inter
interchangeably in SQL World column is
definitely the more correct term the
reason you'll hear developers kind of I
don't know slip up or use the terms
field and call them interchangeably is
because once you convert a row in a
database into a struct or an object then
within the programming language you'd
you'd call that a field on an object
right so for example a person object
might have an ID field all right
um moving on we've got handle which is
text
name which is text
page which is an integer
balance also an integer integer
and finally is admin
is a Boolean
then we end all of our SQL statements
with a semicolon
great I'm gonna go ahead and run that
and just so you're aware this next SQL
statement that's running after the
create table statement just kind of
dumps the information about the people
table so that's why we were able to get
kind of this nice little description of
the table that we just created all the
different columns we created and their
types that looks correct to me I'm going
to go ahead and submit it
now it's extremely rare to work on a web
application that only has one table most
web applications are going to have many
tables usually have a table per entity
so for example in a social media
application you might have a table for
your users a table for their posts maybe
a separate table for all of the comments
on those posts and then maybe even a
separate table keeping track of all the
likes on the posts right well in our
case we're building cash pal which is a
PayPal like clone
um so we'll probably need another table
called transactions this is where we'll
keep track of all of the payments
between users so uh create the create
transactions table with the following
Fields so create
table
transactions
Fields ID integer
recipient
ID integer
sender
ID
sure
note
text
and finally amount integer
perfect right this makes sense every
transaction is going to get a unique ID
to identify that transaction we'll also
need to keep track of the recipient and
the sender in every transaction an
optional note and how much money is
being sent cool let's go ahead and run
that
and that's looking correct to me
now rather than creating a new table
let's talk about changing and existing
tables this would typically be kind of
dangerous right if you have code that
depends on a specific name of a database
table then it can be tricky to kind of
swap the name out live but if you're
working with a toy database or maybe you
haven't pushed to production yet this is
usually a pretty simple thing to get
done we have an alter table statement
that allows us to do it so for example
if we would just want to rename a table
then we can alter table employees rename
it to the contractors table right we can
also rename columns by doing alter table
name of the table and then rename column
salary to invoice for example right so
the same alter table
keywords are used for both altering the
name of the table and the name of
individual columns and then if we're not
actually renaming but instead we're
adding or deleting columns um we
actually still use that same alter table
keyword at the start of the SQL query so
alter table contractors in this case add
column and then the name of the column
and its type
or just alter table contractors drop
column and then the name of the column
so this alter table statement really
gets a lot done for us it's the latter
half of the statement that really kind
of describes what's going on so dropping
down into the assignment here it says we
need to make some changes to the people
table at the moment we have these five
columns shows shown as rows so we can
display data types okay so these are our
columns ID handle name age balance is
admin
rename the table to users rename the
handle column to username and add the
password text column okay so we're
actually going to be writing a few
different SQL commands here and
um just to start I'm going to go ahead
and run the code in its current state it
looks like it looks like the user's
table doesn't exist which if we take a
look at the setup code we can see that
this is kind of what's being run before
our code runs so this makes sense right
the people tables being created and when
we kind of dump the information on the
users table it's not there okay so first
thing we need to do is rename the table
to users so we'll do alter
able people
and then I'm going to double check our
syntax up here rename to rename
two users
and just so that you're aware users is a
very conventional name for the users of
an application you typically would not
name all of the people that are using
your tool in your database you typically
would not name that table people in fact
I explicitly named the table people so
that we could in this exercise change it
to users because that's the much more
kind of standard thing to do
so alter table people rename two users
I'm going to run that
cool now we're getting closer to the
right answer right we're at least we're
at least getting this output that
describes the users table but there's a
couple more instructions rename the
handle column to username okay so after
this we'll do alter table now called
users right alter table users
rename handle to username so it's going
to be rename column
handle to
username
okay
um this one I've seen both ways I
wouldn't say there's necessarily a right
or a wrong answer around handle or
username right Twitter calls them
handles most applications probably call
them usernames but uh it's it's not too
important and I would argue the more
social your app is the more likely
you're probably going to call them
handles
okay cool let's run that now we can see
that we've swapped that handle out for
the username field so that's looking
good and then add the password column
and it should be of type text
so again alter table
users
add column
password
be type text
and let's run that
cool this is looking good to me I'm
going to go ahead and submit it
good database migrations are kind of
like unit tests in the sense that a lot
of people don't actually do them very
well but like to walk around talking
about how great they are I am an
aggressive unit tester if you're
wondering what the hell I'm talking
about this video is for you let's talk
about database migrations let's jump
right into an example let's say that we
have a user's table
in our database
and you the users table has a few Fields
right have an ID
say users have a username
maybe a password
anyways let's say that we've deployed
this application to production so we
actually have users this table is being
used in production by our web
application but what happens is now we
want to add a new feature and the new
feature requires a new field in the
database turns out now we need to add a
new field let's call it birthday
the act of adding that field of adding a
new column to the table that is a
database migration now this type of
migration where we've added add a new
column or add a new table it tends to be
fairly safe
tends to be fairly safe and the reason
for that is the application that's been
connected to this database and running
queries it didn't care about this
birthday field before it was never say
you know querying give me all of the
users whose birthdays are before this
date it wasn't making those queries by
adding a new field it's very
Unbreak anything by adding a new table
to a database that's being used very
unlikely you'll break anything because
the current code simply doesn't care
about that database table because it
just didn't exist in the last version on
the other hand let's say we do a
migration where we remove passwords from
the users table right maybe we're no
longer storing user passwords because we
only support sign in with Google
something like that these types of
migrations right removals of data
remove I'll just do RM they're very
dangerous
they tend to be very dangerous so let's
talk through some rules of thumb about
how you'd approach migrations depending
on if your migration is adding a
resource like a column or a table
deleting a column or a table or updating
because this is going to change a lot
right so let's assume that we're adding
we're adding a new column or a new table
this tends to be safe and so what you
can do first to keep things simple is
first you run the migration on the
database so you update the database
step number one right and by updating
the database you haven't broken what's
currently running because you're just
adding new stuff right again generally
speaking okay number two you'll update
your code
right now you can deploy the new version
of the application that actually uses
those new fields or tables okay now
let's assume that you're deleting a
column or a table the first thing you're
actually going to do in this case is
update the code
right so presumably you're deleting a
column or a table from a database
because you no longer need it in your
application logic right for whatever
reason you don't care about users
birthdays anymore so we're just going to
go ahead and delete it well first you
need to update the code
stop querying that resource right stop
querying that column or that table
once the code has been updated now you
can safely update the database without
breaking anything now let's talk about
the thing that is by far the hardest
this is updating
now generally speaking you should try
just to not update and what I mean is
changing the name of a table is
generally speaking just a really bad
idea changing the name of a column
really bad try to get those things right
the first time but if you do have to
change it just know that it's going to
be more work and you need to be extra
careful because keep in mind when we're
adding stuff
we can safely update the database
beforehand when we're deleting stuff we
can safely update the database after the
fact when we are updating stuff there's
really no safe way I mean think about it
for just a second you've got an old
version of code that expects an old
database name and a new version of code
that expects a new database name really
your only option is to make sure that
you update both the database table name
and the code at exactly the same moment
in time and it's really hard to make
sure that happens you're going to have
probably milliseconds or seconds of
downtime so because this is a harder
problem there's not just a simple one
two solution I'm going to just give a
few ideas of how you can approach
updating a database approach number one
is schedule downtime
downtime so this means you literally
just turn off your application you're
like look customers I'm sorry you cannot
access the application for the next 30
minutes we're doing a big update to our
database
um I don't recommend that that kind of
sucks right people want access to your
web application
um so this is like what you would do if
you really feel like you don't have any
other options it's it's simple but it
does affect your customers number two is
kind of what I described at the start
which is just a same
same time
deploy
right so we're just going to deploy the
update and we're going to deploy the
code at the same time we understand that
there will be kind of a bug there for a
few seconds but if you've determined
that say you don't have any active users
at the moment or a few seconds of issues
aren't really a problem and it's not
worth doing anything more complex I mean
I've seen companies do this I wouldn't
say it's a good idea but it does get the
job done the best approach or the most
robust approach is probably to copy
to copy
the database or the database table right
so we create a new copy of the table
with all the exact same data we can
update the new copies name to be the new
table right and now we can safely deploy
the new code that references the new
table there is a possibility of you know
in the interim of you've done the copy
and now you've deployed the new code
that new records will be added to the
old table that you would also need to
copy but that can also be handled right
you can write a fairly robust migration
script that copies data to the new table
deploys the code makes sure it moves
over any records that were added in the
interim that sort of thing so copying
tends to be very robust it takes a
little more work right you're writing a
a more a more complex migration script
to make sure that everything goes off
without a hitch now I know I just said
that copying was the best approach and I
may have misspoke there there actually
is a better approach that I'm aware of
I'm going to call it aliasing
the thing is sometimes aliasing is not
possible so there are certain databases
that support an aliasing feature and
some that don't so it kind of just
depends if this is available to you but
the whole idea behind aliasing is that
you can give the table a second name so
your database table effectively has two
names that can be referenced by so what
that means is your old code references
the old name you Alias the table with a
second name it's not going to be
referenced by two different names the
new code uses the new name right and
then once you've safely deployed the new
code you can drop the old name from the
table that would actually be the best
the safest and the simplest approach but
it kind of depends on your database
technology and what's available to you
these are just four options
um these are the four that I've tended
to use the most hopefully they help and
then I just want to reiterate that you
shouldn't be updating names very often
right pick good table names pick good
column names try to do ads and deletes
and avoid updates now the last thing we
need to talk about with database
migration
are up
up and down migrations
right so we talked about the different
types of migrations in the sense that
you can add something delete it or
update it but realistically any
migration that brings us forward in time
we call an up migration right so our
first up migration might create
a table
right and then our second migration
might delete
I should say our second up migration
might delete a column from that table
right our third migration might create a
new table create
another table
no let's say our fourth up migration
renames
a column
and then maybe our last migration
deletes
deletes a table
okay those are all up migrations and in
theory
the
latest running or the current running
version of our application we'll just
use
the latest version of the migrations in
other words it will have run every
single up migration in order to arrive
at kind of the final state of the
database the one that's running in
production now a down migration a down
migration is really just used to roll
back changes in the case of emergency or
in the case that something goes wrong so
you don't plan to use your down
migrations you just kind of have them as
a backup and frankly this is why at the
very beginning of the video I talked
about how people talk about great
migrations but oftentimes they don't
employ them
um not every company has great plans for
down migrations uh just just to speak
frankly
um it's more robust to have great down
migration so that you can roll up your
database and roll down your database
Bring It Forward and backward in time
but it's a lot of work right so you
won't necessarily always see uh you know
teams that have fantastic down
migrations but let's just talk about
what they'd look like so a down
migration is very simply just the
opposite of its um kind of related up
migration so when you add a new table
you might also log a down migration that
deletes that same table
so delete table
here we'd have ADD column right we're
just doing the inverse of the equivalent
up migration the third down migration
would delete a table again
delete
table
the fourth would rename the column back
to whatever it was
right it would invert this up migration
and then finally here we would have an
add table command
and that's a five why did I write 6.
there we go okay so the theory is I can
go all the way up to the latest version
by running these up migrations in order
and if I need to go back a version I can
just run the equivalent down migration
right so I get up to the latest and then
I say oh crap I need to roll back to the
late the last version of my database I
can just run this down migration number
five to re-add that table that I just
deleted so as we just talked about
database migrations can be pretty
dangerous they tend to be some of the
more dangerous things that you do when
working with databases like with all web
development the closer you get to the
data the more careful you have to be
right bugs that you push to production
are generally pretty easy to revert and
get the right code pushed out to users
and get the bug fixed when you mess up
data sometimes it could be harder to
revert those changes so you always have
to be more careful when you're working
with kind of the persisted data that
sticks around in your database because
sometimes just changing the code back to
what it was won't necessarily res revert
the state of the file system in the
database this is a pretty solid meme
regarding uh production databases I've
I've definitely been the dog in this
situation you don't want to be the dev
that alters the production database and
brings the side down it's it's actually
it's not fine
moving on uh the question associated
with uh this first lesson about database
migration says which of the following
statements about migrations is false so
first one is you can be fast and loose
when writing migrations a bad migration
is easy to fix that is false I'm going
to read the rest of them just uh just to
make sure nothing else is even worse
um well-written migrations are
reversible that's generally true right
you can go up and you can go down uh
that doesn't necessarily mean you always
want to be doing that but they they they
are reversible
a good migration takes into account any
systems that rely on the existing schema
that is true you need to make sure you
don't have any active code that's
relying on an old version of the
database migrations are incremental
changes made to a database that is true
Okay cool so it is this one you should
not be fast and loose with migrations
they are not easy to fix if you get them
wrong
the next question is will database
migrations often be coupled with
application code updates
um and that is generally speaking true
right you want to roll the database
forward to a new version along with the
new code that uses that new schema
the next question says why are good
migrations written in a reversible
Manner and the answers are they are not
so that if something goes wrong the
changes can be rolled back or because
you should always roll back changes
before applying new ones
um
well they are good migrations are
written in reversible manner so it's not
the first one
um you don't always need to roll back
changes before applying new ones that's
that's not how migrations work usually
you'll add one new incremental migration
and just roll that one forward
um the middle one so that if something
goes wrong the changes can be rolled
back that is that is the real that is
the real reason it's important to
understand though that just by rolling
back the schema changes doesn't
necessarily mean you've fixed the data
so it just kind of depends on what quote
unquote went wrong but in at least when
you have good down migrations you can
bring the schema back to where it's
supposed to be so it's going to be that
middle one so we've talked about this a
little bit before but when you're
writing reversible migrations the term
up and down migrations uh really are
used to refer to kind of the chronology
so you'll put every new change to the
database schema in subsequent up
migrations right so your first migration
might create a new table the next one
might add a column
etc etc and every down migration has one
Associated up migration okay our
assignment here where we'll be
practicing with some migrations is to
add an additional column to the
transactions table we want to know
whether or not the transaction was
successfully completed between two users
we also want to know or we also want our
database to track the type of
transactions so our transactions table
looks like this at the moment
okay complete the up migration complete
the following up migration
add the Boolean was successful column to
the transactions table and then add the
text transaction type column to the
transactions table Okay cool so we'll be
adding two columns
alter
table
transactions
add column
was successful
Boolean
an alter table transactions
add column
transaction type
next
cool let's go ahead and take a look at
that
was successful Boolean transaction type
text looks good to me
let's talk about some data types so as
I've mentioned before we're actually
using SQL Lite in this course and the
data types that are available to you
kind of do depend on the specific
database engine that you're using right
so we're using SQL Lite and so you'll
see types like null which means
nothing's there and actually that is
pretty ubiquitous basically every SQL
database I've ever worked with supports
null values
um you've got integer types which are
you know
whole numbers that can also be negative
right so negative one negative two zero
one two three four Etc signed integers
um reels this is your equivalent of like
a floating point value or a double
depending on what programming language
you're coming from but basically numbers
with a fractional part
you've got text fields and then blobs
which are basically just like big blobs
of binary data
um and then the other thing to keep in
mind when working with SQL Lite is just
that Boolean values uh false and true
you can use the kind of keywords false
and true in your SQL but when you get
the data back it will be represented as
as ones and zeros I think the only other
thing really worth pointing out at this
point is that the text field is
supported by most other large databases
think you know postgres MySQL but they
also have an additional type of text
field called a varchar and you would
typically use a varchar if you know
exactly how long your text field is
going to be like say you know it's going
to be 36 characters long like maybe
you're storing I don't know password
hashes or or emails and you know that
there's a maximum link to emails and the
reason you would do that usually is for
performance reasons if you can tell the
database hey this field is never going
to store data larger than 36 characters
then the database can make certain
optimizations to keep the database kind
of fast in the file system right keep
your queries a little more performant
but sqlite it just doesn't deal with
that right it's a little more
loosey-goosey with how it deals with
data in case you're wondering why it's
called a VAR Char that's kind of
shorthand for character varying right so
a varying amount of characters but again
you would actually specify exactly how
many characters when you use that type
of column so again in this course we'll
just keep it simple use the text type so
the question is how is a true Boolean
value stored and presented in sqlite and
we've got the string true the string
false one or zero true is the Boolean
value one
next question presented as a statement
says all SQL databases support the same
data types that is false
next question what type would you use to
store a user's email well of these types
we've got integers reals texts blobs I
guess technically you could like convert
the email address to a binary number
stored as a blob or frankly even maybe
an integer or real if there's enough uh
if there's enough data there but
realistically come on you should be
storing it as a text field if you're
using sqlite again if you're using MySQL
or postgres you might use like a varchar
36 or something like that
it's really important to understand null
values in SQL because it's not
necessarily the most intuitive thing uh
you've probably ever encountered so a
null value indicates the absence of a
value so for example if you have a
column called username and a row in that
table
has a cell that is the empty string then
technically that is a username
of string length zero right and that's
different than if you actually
explicitly set the value of that cell to
null which is used to indicate that
there's there's nothing there right so
generally speaking you want to prefer to
use nulls rather than like empty strings
or zeros or false in the case of a
Boolean value when you're trying to
represent the fact that there's there's
nothing here it's probably worth
mentioning that the idea of null in SQL
is very similar to the idea of none if
you're coming from the python world or
null if you're coming from the
JavaScript world or nil if you're coming
from the go programming language and one
of the neat things we can do in SQL is
actually set constraints on our database
schema and say we never want a specific
column to be allowed to house nulls
right so that protects us and says we'll
never accidentally insert for example a
user into a database without making sure
that they have an email okay enough
about nulls and constraints let's jump
into the assignment because we didn't
force any constraints on our tables when
we created them earlier and it has
allowed for null entries to make their
way into our table let's take a look at
our transactions table and see what
those null values look like write a
query to select all of the fields on all
of the records of the transactions table
so select
star that's all of the columns or all of
the fields right
um from
transactions
let's go ahead and run that
and we can see
notice that there's a bunch of data just
seemingly missing right that's because
those cells have the null value in them
and it looks like that's all we have to
do for this assignment so I'm going to
go ahead and submit it so we talked a
little bit about constraints in the last
lesson but now we're going to actually
use them and essentially a constraint is
just a rule that enforces something
about our schema right so again for
example if we have a users table and we
want to make sure that we never
accidentally insert a user into that
table without ensuring that they have a
valid email address we could add a not
null constraint on the email column now
how do we actually Define a constraint
so the constraint just comes after the
type in for example a create table
statement so ID is the name of the
column and then we have integer the type
and then the constraint right in the
case the ID there's a primary key
constraint which we'll talk more about
later we've got a unique constraint on
the name again we'll talk about that one
later and then here you'll see the not
null constraint that we're putting on
the title okay let's jump into the
assignment it says thankfully all the
tables we've created for cashpile up to
this point have been for testing
purposes now that we have a better
understanding of constraints let's
rebuild our database with the proper
constraints and tables create the users
table with the following fields and
constraints so we're going to need a
create
table statement table is going to be
called users
field is ID it's an integer type
and the constraint is going to be
primary key
really quickly let's just talk about
what the primary key constraint means so
a the primary key constraint means that
ID is going to need to be unique for
every new row so if I add a user with
id1 and then I try to add another user
with id1 then the database should error
and get mad at me right because they're
not unique so that's the first thing the
second thing the primary key constraint
does is
um that you can only use the primary key
Once On Any Given table right that's why
we're calling it a primary key so you'll
most often see primary keys on some sort
of ID column one last thing worth
mentioning that the primary key
constraint does is that it is also it
doubles as a not null constraint so you
can almost kind of think of a primary
key constraint as both a unique
constraint and a not null constraint
right so we want to make sure that an ID
is present on every single user record
in this case moving on we've got a name
field it's going to be text and it's
just going to have a not null constraint
right so keep in mind that means the
name field can be the same on different
rows right we can have two users with
the same name not a problem
um we just can't have it missing right
in this case okay next we've got age
it's an integer integer see if I can
spell it's also going to be not null we
want to make sure we've logged an age
for everyone next we've got a country
code we want to know what country our
users are living in
that'll be an integer oh no excuse me
that'll be text
and it will be not null
next we've got a username
also text in this case is going to be
unique
now
the primary difference between unique
and primary key is that a you can use
unique you can use a unique constraint
on multiple columns so you won't just
have one unique column and also unique
columns can typically be nulled so
that's not necessarily a problem
all right
I should capitalize this use proper
conventions so unique
next we'll need a password
text
not null
and is admin gonna be a Boolean with no
constraints on that one
finished up with a semicolon let's go
ahead and run that see what we get
SQL logic error near closing parenthesis
ah I have a trailing comma here that I
do not need run it again
cool
so we can see the names of all the
columns we can see the types and we've
got you can see the constraint here of
whether it's not null you can see the
primary key there this is looking good
to me I'm going to go ahead and submit
it
so I already kind of did a spoiler of
this exercise but I'll go ahead and just
kind of give you the rigmarole again a
primary key is a constraint that is
effectively adds a not null right so you
can't have null primary Keys you can't
have duplicates so they're effectively
unique and you can only have one primary
key on a table and most of the time
you'll see this a lot especially in
backend web development most of the time
you'll have an ID column on a database
and that column will be the primary key
sometimes you might be tempted as a web
developer to make a column like email
the primary key right thinking to
yourself well we don't allow any two
users in our database to use the same
email so we might as well just make it
the primary key and kind of use it as an
ID I would definitely recommend against
this it's definitely best practice to
have a specific column called ID that is
used as the identifier for that Row in
the database and the main reason for
this this is sometimes business logic
changes right maybe in the future you
will allow users to have the same email
address and if you've been using that
email address as a unique identifier all
over the place in your code base or in
your systems it's really hard to undo
that change so just coming right out of
the gate with you know we're going to
put a unique identifier on every single
row and that's never going to change
that can save you a lot of hassle in the
future so let's hop down into the
assignment it says run the code and
notice there's a book okay let's run it
constraint failed unique constraint
failed users dot ID all right there's a
violation of a primary key constraint on
the ID column fix the data that's being
inserted when working with integers IDs
it's best practice to increment the ID
by one for each successive insert follow
this convention when fixing the book
okay so if I look at this code
I can see there's two inserts happening
and it looks like the first insert is
inserting a value of 0 for the ID
the next one is also using a value of
zero so to fix this bug I should be able
to just change this to a one
cool now we've got two rows in our
database first one with ID 0 second with
ID one I'm gonna submit that next we've
got foreign keys right so we just talked
about primary Keys which are an ID on an
individual table that kind of identifies
every Row in that table a foreign key
is just a key in a table that references
the ID of another table so it's it's
really what makes databases relational
right this is how we relate data in one
table to data in another table now you
don't technically need to add a foreign
key
constraints on a yield and a table to
make it a foreign key right remember a
foreign key kind of just references an
ID in another table right so if I have a
user's table and there's a user in there
with id4 and then I have my transactions
table and it has a column called you
know user underscore ID
with an id4 then it's You could argue
it's it's referencing that other table
right just kind of inherently however
there is an explicit foreign key
constraint that we can add to Fields you
can see that syntax right here and the
reason you would use that constraint is
to ensure that when you're referencing a
specific uh foreign key or I guess in
your table to foreign key in the table
that you're referencing it's it's that
primary key but what it does is it
ensures that that key actually exists in
the other table right so when I create a
transaction say
with user id4 right so my foreign key is
a primary key of my user
so this transaction is for user number
four
that foreign key constraint will make
sure that in the users table there
actually is a user with id4 and if there
isn't then it will throw an error right
so it's a way to make sure that my
relationships actually exist in my
database this is one of those things
that's kind of hard to understand in the
abstract so let's take a look at this
example so let's say we have a
departments table
and each department has an ID which is
its primary key right so something
identifying each individual department
and then it's got a name for the
Department great and then let's say we
have another table employees each
employee also has its own ID right so
keep in mind we've got a primary key for
both tables now employees of course can
belong to departments so we're going to
store a department ID on the employees
table right this will tell us which
department the employee is in this is
referencing the other table now this is
a foreign key
right because it's referencing the
primary key of another table
but we're also going to add a constraint
called foreign key departments in this
case right we just name our our
constraint technically whatever we want
but it's nice to be descriptive so
foreign key departments it's going to be
a foreign key on our department ID field
referencing the Department's table
and the ID column from that table right
so by adding this constraint
if we try to create a new employee in a
department that doesn't exist
the constraint will come into effect and
give us an error let's hop down into the
assignment it says our users Table
stores the country our users are from in
a country code field Okay so we've got
country code on the users table we need
some additional data about countries
like their name but we don't want to
bloat our users table with all that
country data that makes sense right we
want to keep country data kind of in its
own table the locations team at Cash pal
has created a countries table and we can
link a user to their country by setting
a foreign key in the users table take a
look take a look at the code there's an
issue with the insert statements again
fix up the data so no foreign key
constraints are violated you'll need to
reference the setup code below okay so
I'm going to take a look at this setup
code
looks like we're creating a user's table
with that country code
and it looks like some data is being
inserted into the country's table
oh and here's the here's the create
table statement for the countries table
so it's just got a code and a name
okay and then we'll have United States
that's in the country's table and we
also have India codes us and in let's go
ahead and run the code in its current
state to see what happens and straight
failed foreign key constraint failed
okay so this first user is going to
reference
us that that should work right we have
we have an ID of us here that that's
fine
but here ah so we're inserting again
into the user table but here it looks
like this was mistyped right it's
supposed to reference i n as the country
code for India but it's got IND so just
removing that D should fix this up
there we go
so I've used this word schema a few
times so far in this course and I really
just want to talk about what it means
basically a database schema is just the
shape that you're using to Define your
data right so for example the number of
tables in your database is part of your
schema the names of those tables is part
of the schema the names and data types
of all of the columns in your tables
that's all part of your schema so really
a schema just tells you how is data
organized within this database now it's
important to point out there is no
perfect database schema for your app
there's lots of different ways that you
could model the data that makes your
application run you kind of just need to
pick one and there are a few rules of
thumb for picking a good one which of
course we'll talk about in just a second
so get your database schema as best you
can to model what's going on in your
application and honestly my rule of
thumb is try to keep it as simple as you
possibly can while accurately modeling
relationships if you keep it simple it's
always easy to add complexity that adds
functionality later whereas if you add a
bunch of complexity up front oftentimes
it can be harder to strip back that
complexity into Simplicity down the road
so to start getting specific we can use
cache pal as an example it says one very
important decision that needs to be made
is to decide which table will store a
user's balance as you can imagine
ensuring our data is accurate when
dealing with money is super important we
want to be able to keep track of a
user's balance
see the historic balance at any point in
the past and see a log of which
transactions change the balance over
time right so to be able to essentially
audit the balance as it changes right
people are curious as to all of the
transactions they've had in the past so
we need to make sure that we don't like
overwrite that data or lose that data
there are many ways to approach this
problem for our first attempt let's try
the simplest schema that fulfills our
project's needs again we're always going
to try to opt for Simplicity first so
jumping into the assignment says the
architecture team at Cash Palace decided
on a single transactions table the
transactions Table stores individual
transactions and we can keep track of
the current balance on each transaction
record if we want the current balance we
just look at the most recent transaction
so create the transactions table with
the following fields and constraints all
right create
table
transactions
gonna be an ID integer
primary key
sender ID
integer
recipient
ID integer
memo text not null
mount
integer not null
and finally the balance
now you might be wondering I don't think
I've addressed this yet why we're using
integers here for amount and balance
instead of reals which are like floating
Point numbers right and the reason is in
financial applications it's actually
very common to store money as an integer
and just store it in the units of like
like the smaller units so for example
rather than storing our money in dollars
and storing like 5.67 right 5.67 we
store it as pennies so when you have
five dollars we just store 500 right you
have 500 pennies and the reason for that
is floating Point arithmetic has like
rounding issues in computation whereas
integers don't have those issues so if
we just use integers keep it simple then
we don't have any of those potential
data Integrity issues that you get with
floating Point numbers I'm not going to
go super into detail on all the issues
you can get with floating Point numbers
you can definitely go look that up just
know that that's why you'll see integers
very often used in financial
applications okay now that we've written
our create table statement let me go
ahead and run that
see if we get what we expect this looks
good to me I'm going to go ahead and
submit
so we've been using the term relational
quite a bit throughout this course but
we haven't really talked about what it
means a relational database is just a
type of database that stores data that
can be related to other pieces of data
right so in the case of Twitter a user
is related to their tweets right and
relational databases are just databases
that keep that in mind right they make
it really easy to relate different
entities between tables so some
properties of relational databases are
data is typically represented in tables
okay that's how we've been doing it
throughout this course so far each table
has columns or fields that hold
attributes related to that record right
so in this in this image for example
we've got a students table and then
there's two columns the ID column and
the name column or the ID field and the
name field column is the more accurate
database term but you'll hear feel used
just because fields are often used in
kind of more traditional programming
languages like python or go or
JavaScript
each row or entry in the table is called
a record right so this first record in
the student courses table for example
has student id1 and course id1 and then
typically each record has a unique ID
called the primary key now that's not
always the case that's why I say
typically so maybe nine times out of ten
you'll have an ID column on a table so
that it's really easy to identify each
unique record in the table so let's
answer this question it says how many
courses is Sam enrolled in right so
we've got our relational database here
and we can see that Sam is ID number one
in the students table right so we're
trying to figure out how many courses
he's enrolled in well let's look up the
student courses table we can see that
student ID 1 which is Sam right because
we we have that relationship over here
we can see he's enrolled in three
different courses
right we have three rows in the student
courses table he's enrolled in course
one two and three so the answer is going
to be three there
the next question is how many students
are in the mongodb course okay so this
time I'm going to start at the courses
table look up the mongodb course I can
see it here it's got an ID of three so
looking at the student courses table I
can see there's three rows that
reference the mongodb course right with
ID3
and I see students one two and three so
all three students are in the mongodb
course so gonna be three again
so we know what a relational database
looks like right with tables and keys
that kind of point to each other and
reference each other uh to build
relationships the question is what's a
non-relational database and I mean most
simply put a non-relational database is
just a database that doesn't support
those kinds of complex relationships
between data and typically when we're
talking about like no SQL non-relational
databases we're talking about databases
that Nest data so rather than using keys
to reference other data and keeping
everything kind of nice and tight and
normalized which is a concept that we'll
talk about more later they just kind of
lazily Nest the data within itself which
does have benefits I'm not trying to say
that non-relational databases are always
a bad thing but it's important to
understand some of the trade-offs so to
oversimplify it you can kind of think of
a non-relational database or most
non-relational databases it's just giant
blobs of Json data data right
javascript's object notation for example
if a user can have multiple courses you
might just add all the courses to the
user record so for example in this
database we've got one kind of top level
Json object and then we have this key
users
which holds an array or a list a list of
things right and in this case we've got
one user with id0 the name is Elon
and then we've got a nested list or
nested array of courses so we're
actually storing each course on top of
each user record which means if we were
to add another user to this array
right like we add Bob for example and we
want to put Bob in the biology class we
would actually need to store a copy of
the biology classes information under
the Bob record right so now instead of
having one course and one user and
having them reference each other
we have to have a user and their copy of
the course right so it kind of in in
some instances creates data redundancy
in the system so here's a visual example
right we've got in the relational
database we have a posts table and a
comments table and the posts will
reference the comments or actually the
comments will reference the original
post so every time you have a new
comment added to the system it will just
reference the original post whereas in a
non-relational database what you'd
actually do is just have one posts table
or you know whatever the database
happens to call the the kind of
equivalent idea of a table and you just
Nest all of the individual comments
within each post so in this case it
probably is fine right because a comment
can't really be a comment on two posts
most likely but it does get to be more
of a problem when you do have those many
to many relationships that that
relational databases make really easy so
the question says relational databases
typically blank duplicate data while
non-relational databases often blank
duplicate data so do duplicate data or
Do Not Duplicate data and typically
relational databases are very good about
not duplicating data so they Do Not
Duplicate data whereas non-relational
databases or nosql databases kind of are
okay with duplicating some data again
usually with some sort of trade-off and
we'll talk about some of those
trade-offs later
the next question is non-relational
databases connect similar entities by
using blank got nestadata keys Flubber
and concurrency and the answer is nested
data and I I will point out that this
question should probably be a little
more loose and say typically connect
similar entities by using nested data
because there are no SQL data bases that
do allow for more complex
um
well I should say there there are other
Alternatives aside from just nesting
data in fact some non-relational
databases are so simple that you
couldn't even Nest data in them if you
wanted to right maybe they're just very
simple key value stores so just kind of
keep that in mind
let's talk about crud or
c-r-u-d which stands for create read
update and delete these four operations
really are the bread and butter of all
things data all things databases right
and HTTP and crud map very well to one
another so your typical backend web
server in like a very standard web
application will often be referred to as
a crud server because it very simply
Maps HTTP requests to database
operations so for example an HTTP post
request will very often create a new
record in a database whereas an HTTP get
request we'll perform a database read
and HTTP put will update something and
an HTTP delete will delete something so
in the simplest web applications again
your server is really just reading an
HTTP request and kind of deciding what
it needs to do to the the database I
need to create read update or delete so
moving on to the assignment it says
we've created a table for you called
crud it's a toy table that we're using
for interview practice at cashpow
determine which SQL command can be used
for a read operation and use it to read
all of the fields in all of the records
in the cred table cool so it's just
going to be a select star from crud
let's run that
cool and you can see here it looks like
the table is filled with those mappings
of HTTP methods to in this case actually
database keywords so read select yeah
makes sense I'm gonna go ahead and
submit that we've done a lot of
selecting so far and we've done a lot
with schemas but now it's time to look
at how we can insert data into a
database so there is in fact an insert
statement and it looks like this so
insert into
table name
followed by a list of fields
and then the values that we want to
insert into those fields or insert into
those columns the assignment says let's
start manually adding some of the
records to our users table take a look
at the create table statement in the
setup code below for the user's table
structure and use that information to
insert the following records under the
table okay so we're going to be
inserting record one and record two
let's take a look at that schema here
so we've got this create table users
okay we can see what columns are
available to us it looks like we need to
write our insert statements here so
insert into
users
and then we need to do
the names of the columns we want to
insert into
I'll actually put this on a new line
so it's going to be ID
name
age country code
username
password
and is admin
and it's going to be values and then all
the actual values we want to add so
values
so 1
David
us
David Dev the username
insert practice is the password and is
admin is false and we end it all with a
semicolon
oh okay
so just to be clear
order matters here
right so the first key I'm passing into
this insert statement is the ID column
which means the first value needs to be
the ID value make sense
cool uh and we have one more record to
insert
the good news is all of
column names are the same
now we just need to change up the values
so it's going to be id2
name Samantha page 29 looks like she's
in Brazil
username sammy93
password adding records and ISM admin is
still false cool go ahead and run that
seems to have worked
gonna go ahead and submit
let's talk about how data flows through
your typical web application so take a
look at this diagram here
we've got the front end of our web
application in this case looks like it's
a mobile device or a mobile app
we have the backend web server which is
what we as backend developers are
primarily responsible for coding up
and then we've got the database right
could be sqlite postgres my SQL whatever
and the way that these three things
typically communicate with each other is
that the front end communicates with the
back end over HTTP so HTTP get requests
post requests put delete whatever right
and the backend server commit
communicates with the database itself
using SQL by the way I want to point out
if you've gotten this far on the course
and you're hearing me say HTTP post get
put whatever and you're not
understanding what I'm talking about I
do have an HTTP course that I'd
recommend you take before this course so
you might want to pause your progress on
this course go look up my HTTP course
check that out and then come back so
just so you're aware I'm kind of
assuming that you understand at least
the basics of HTTP requests as they
relate to web development cool so the
front end process is some data from user
input maybe a form is submitted right
maybe a button is clicked whatever
front-end sends that data to the back
end via an HTTP request and then the
HTTP request is kind of converted into a
SQL statement in the backend server
sends that's the database right so let's
take an example of a new user is
registering so the new user enters an
email a password clicks a button the
front end sends a post request to the
database with the new username and
password
the excuse me let me let me rewind that
just a second the front end sends a post
request to the web server
an HTTP post request to the web server
with a username and password the server
takes that username and password from
the post request converts it into an SQL
statement and executes the SQL statement
against the database right probably
inserting a user record if that
operation succeeds then the HTTP post
request will be responded to by the web
server and the front end will get a
happy 200 okay Response Code so the
question here is a front-end typically
communicates with a database directly to
add new records and then the answers are
false and true
um no it is unusual for a front-end to
interact directly with a backend
database there are exceptions here
um it it can be the case that the
front-end application is actually
running a database locally right for
example SQL Lite is very often used as
kind of an embedded database but that
doesn't work if your application wants
to store data on the cloud for example
right that would be like a local only
application that would do something like
that so in your typical kind of web
application
um architecture where data is stored on
the cloud and kind of travels across
devices
um the front end won't often will not
often communicate directly to a database
so
um
this is false
the next question is the create in crud
maps to which SQL statement and HTTP
method
um and it's going to be well in SQL it's
an insert right that will create a
record and in HTTP that would typically
be a post let's talk about the auto
increment keyword so the automate the
auto increment keyword in SQL is a
feature supported by most SQL databases
that effectively allows you to
automatically increment the values in a
given column so for example this is most
common with an ID column so you have an
ID column that is integer primary keys
right so every new say user in your
database you want them to have a new ID
and you want to increment by one every
time so let's just say that you've got
this user's table it's got its ID column
and you've got four records in the
database and they have IDs one two three
and four what the auto increment keyword
allows you to do is when you insert that
fifth record you actually don't have to
specify in your SQL statement that its
ID is going to be five
you can just say hey please Auto
increment this column and the database
will automatically check and say oh I'm
already using IDs you know one through
four so this new record is going to have
id5 that's useful because it means when
you insert a new record you don't first
have to do a database read to check
which IDs are available or which ID you
should use next Now quickly before we
jump into the assignment I do want to
call out that while this Paradigm of
using an integer ID that auto increments
is fairly common you'll also see a lot
of uuids out there in the world and to
summarize a uuid is basically a randomly
generated ID right so instead of every
record having an ID that just increments
by one number you'll be generating a
very large random number as your ID for
every record and again the nice thing
about that is you don't have to do a
read before you do an insert because you
can just kind of generate a huge number
randomly and be fairly confident that
and when I say fairly I mean extremely
like it's essentially mathematically
it's nearly impossible to have duplicate
uh uuids because there's just so many
possible combinations but
um that is something you'll see out in
the wild we won't be doing them here if
you want to go Google uuids
um please do so they're very interesting
um those are kind of the two main ways
that I've seen uh primary key IDs
handled in production databases so
jumping into the assignment it says
let's add some more records but allow
the database to automatically increment
the ID field add the following records
to the database okay straightforward
um and the interesting thing to note
here is that it says uh sqlite or in
sqlite an integer ID field so if its
name is ID
and it has a primary key constraint it
will automatically Auto increment by
default so in some databases you
actually do need to like specify Auto
increment in the table creation but you
can see down here
in the setup code there's actually no
Auto increments
uh keyword added to the ID column sqlite
is just doing it by default so
go ahead and get these uh Records
inserted
this is the state of the database at the
moment
right you can see in the setup code it's
it's inserting a bunch of users ahead of
time
we need to write our own insert same so
insert
into users
and we've got name age
country code
username
password
is admin again we don't need to use
the ID column because it will be done
automatically for us and values
what Lance
us
there's a username
there's a password
and then is admin is false
we'll need another one of these
time we've got
Tiffany
it's 28 she's in the US username
tiffaroon
Auto increments
keeping keep in mind Auto increment is
just just happens to be Tiffany's
password
um and she is an admin
go ahead and run that
well and you can see that it
automatically used ID 7 and 8. this
looks good to me
now at this point in the course you
might be wondering gee this seems really
inconvenient every time I need to insert
something into my web applications
database I have to go manually write
some SQL to do it uh no that's that's
not how it works at all when you're sort
of just poking around through your
applications database maybe trying to
figure out what the schema looks like
maybe just doing some research trying to
figure out you know how many users your
application has at that point you will
just kind of be manually doing SQL
queries right you might have some SQL
client like PG admin if you're using
postgres or SQL workbench you'll
probably just be writing manual SQL
queries connected to your database when
you're actually writing back-end servers
you probably will not be writing one-off
SQL statements instead what you'll be
doing is writing SQL
but using kind of dynamic interpolation
to inject values into the SQL let me let
me show you what I mean
so here's some go code for example that
you I don't want to say that you'd see
this in production because there's
actually safer ways to do this but I
think it gets the idea across
here we've got an SQL statement right
insert into user's name age country code
values and then you'll see we've got
these Dynamic placeholders percent s
percent V percent s
in go these placeholders will get
replaced
by whatever these values are that come
afterwards so the user's name the user's
age and the user's country code so this
is more like what you would see in a
production application right you've got
some SQL but it's being dynamically
generated either by your programming
language or by your programming
framework and I also just want to
overstate that you probably won't see
something quite this simple right in go
you probably won't just see fmt.s printf
if you're coming from the JavaScript
world you probably won't just see a
template literal with you know values
injected and the primary reason for that
is because there's this whole area of
security concerns called SQL injection
where basically depending on what those
Dynamic values are people can actually
kind of hack your query and cause your
query to do things that you didn't
intend the good news is that basically
every Library any any good library that
allows you to connect to a production
database should handle SQL injection for
you for example in go the standard
libraries database SQL package handles
this for you so you will see something
that looks like this but there's
probably
a specific method or function that
you'll be calling that handles potential
SQL injection for you so
the important thing to take away from
all of this is just that your SQL
statements will likely be generated
dynamically in your programming language
so question here every time someone
creates an account on boot.dev Alan or
Lane has to manually add them to the
database By Hand by writing a SQL query
that is false right we've automated this
whole process in our backend server
next question is within backend systems
SQL queries are typically blank
generated by code or written by hand so
I mean to be fair like this template is
typically written by hand but then the
kind of end query that's run against the
database is generated by code so I'm
going to go with generated by code on
this one it's often useful to to get the
count of the records in a table rather
than just getting all of the records in
a table so we can use a select statement
to get a count of the records this can
be useful when we want to know how many
there are right so here's an example is
sqlite
select count which is actually a
function
of star from employees now this can
actually be kind of weird the first time
you read it right why am I selecting a
count of star or account of wild card
well in reality the count function takes
field names right so you can count on
individual fields or individual columns
but if you just want to know the total
number of rows then you can just use a
wild card to say I don't really care
about
which column I'm counting so
uh the assignment says here's the
current state of our users table cool so
we've got uh what eight different users
a bunch of fields whatever it says our
base our business strategy team at
cashpow wants to know how many users of
the app we have we can't use the ID
number to calculate the count because
user accounts can be deleted right so
maybe one day John is deleted we can't
just look at the current ID because
Tiffany would still have id8 even if we
deleted John right we'd just be missing
uh kind of a record for ID3
so
we need to use account statement to
retrieve the number of Records in the
users table let's go ahead and write
that so select
out
star and again star is referring to
column names but I don't care I'm just
trying to get the total number of rows I
don't care you know uh whether a name is
present or a name is not present I just
want total number of rows so we'll use
the wild card select count star from
users
run that
cool Count star
so earlier we talked about how a create
operation throws flows through the
architecture of a web application but
now let's talk about a read so again
we've got our front end our backend
server and our database here in the
diagram
in fact Let Me Grow this just a little
bit
first thing that happens when we want to
do a read is that the mobile application
will send probably an HTTP get request
to the server right by convention that's
a pretty common way to do it at that
point the backend server will fire off a
select statement to the database right
what it gets back from the database are
a essentially a table of rows right it
will parse that table of rows and do
some sort of conversion into something
that it can send back in the HTTP
response very often it will be a Json
object
so that's that's pretty standard
operating procedure this is not how it
has to work this is not the only way web
applications are built but it is a very
common convention especially for restful
apis
so the question here is the HTTP method
that generally corresponds with a SQL
select statement is an HTTP blank we've
got patch update get input and it's
going to be a get
next question is which happens first a
select statement is executed a get
request is made or a Json response is
sent and in this case it's going to be a
get request is made that's the very
first thing that happens right we can't
execute a select statement until the
front end makes a get request we can't
send a response until we get the request
in the first place
let's talk about the where Clause so
you'll see the where Clause all the time
in fact it's actually pretty unusual to
make a select statement in SQL without
using a where Clause because the where
Clause allows us to filter down the data
and unless your database only has like
eight rows in it which would be pretty
crazy for a production database you'll
probably want to filter down your result
set so what does that actually look like
in syntax well here's an example select
name from users where power level is
over nine thousand or I should say
greater than or equal to nine thousand
so this will return all of the rows
from the users table sorry it will
return the name column or the values in
the name column
from the users table
where the power level which is a
different column right not the name
column but the power level column is
greater than or equal to 9000.
so
the assignment says we need to know the
username of all of the users in our
users table that have admin privileges
retrieve them
let's start with something simple let's
do select
star from users
I'm going to go ahead and run this and
this will just allow us to see our full
our full data set
so this is just everything in the users
table now we want to filter down to just
the rows
just the rows where the user has admin
privileges or there is admin flag it
sets too so I'm going to go ahead and
say select star from users where is
admin
is true
go ahead and run that
it looks like we've properly filtered
down the result set the last thing is
that it says we just want the username
so I'm going to change this star
username I would expect just to get
aliers and tiffaroon
cool let's submit it
we already know what a null value is but
now let's talk about how we can filter
down to either just the no values or
maybe ignore the null values right
so there's actually two special ways to
deal with null values in SQL you've got
the is null syntax and the is not null
syntax so for example select name from
users where first name is null right or
is not null in the other example
the assignment says the way we store
transactions at cache pal is interesting
we store a user ID field on the
transactions table that user is the
owner of the transaction and a user ID
is never null
okay whenever the owner of the
transaction receives money the sender ID
will not be null
so let's think about that for a second
so you've got a transaction with a user
ID so that that user owns this
transaction
if if they are the receiver of money the
sender ID will not be null because it
will include the ID of the sender right
so when the sender ID is not null we can
see who sent the kind of owner of the
transaction the money and then the
opposite is also true if the owner of
the transaction is the sender then the
recipient ID will not be null because
that ID will point to the receiver of
the money start to make sense
all right so select all of the rows from
the transactions table where the owner
of the transactions is receiving money
okay I'm just going to look at the setup
code
so transactions we've got an ID for the
transaction user ID recipient ID sender
ID and amount okay
so select Star right so select all all
the rows from the transactions table
or the owner of the transaction is
receiving money
so select star
from transactions
where
if they're receiving money there needs
to be a sender right so where sender
ID is not well
run that
cool and as we'd expect the recipient's
ID on these is null because the user is
the recipient
so let's go ahead and submit that
let's talk about deleting now so when a
user deletes their account on Twitter or
deletes a comment on a YouTube video
that data actually needs to be removed
from those respected or those respective
databases right so when you delete your
Tweet we need to actually go purge it
from the database right the Twitter
database in SQL there is a delete
statement
looks like this so delete from table
name
and then optionally you can say where
something equals something or you know
where something is greater than or less
than or whatever right but the point is
delete from table name is kind of the
different thing
um a couple of things I want to point
out here if you just do delete from
employees
that will delete everything in the
employees database
right so for example if I just do
delete from users here
everything's gone right that's like
super dangerous so when you're working
with a production database be very very
careful with your delete statements you
do not want to delete the data
um when you're you know not
intentionally trying to delete the data
the difference between delete from users
and delete from users where
you know ID
equals three
is is a huge difference this will delete
one user
whereas if I remove that where Clause
that just says delete all users in fact
a rule of thumb that I just personally
have is anytime I'm going to run a
delete statement against a production
database I always run it as a select
statement first just to make sure that I
got my where Clause right right just to
make sure and I can kind of see
everything that's going to be deleted by
running a select first so
again when you're working with
production data run a select see all of
the stuff that you're going to delete
and then just change it into a delete
statement run that okay the assignment
says
Samantha one of our cash pal users has
opted to delete her account and stop
using her app which of course makes us
sad anyways we need to remove her record
from the database so delete Samantha's
record from the user table
this is what our users table looks like
at the moment so it looks like Samantha
has ID 2.
now something to point out here
it just so happens that we could write
we could write this SQL query
uh delete from users
where
name equals
Samantha
okay we could run this in fact let me
run it
and it works right Samantha's gone
there's a devious little problem with
this right it's very likely that if our
app is popular that there's many
Samanthas in the database so this is
actually a really bad query to run we
could potentially delete you know 20
different user records all of whom are
named Samantha so generally speaking if
you know you just want to delete one
record use the primary key right so
we're going to do where ID equals two
this is much much safer we're guaranteed
to only delete the row we care about all
right so I'm gonna go ahead and submit
it in this form
the wisest senior developers are the
first to admit that their code base is a
flaming pile of bug-ridden garbage that
has somehow survived in production as
long as it has so because you and your
team are always just one bad commit away
from wiping out all of your customers
data don't you think it'd be smart to
back up your production databases so
let's talk about how you would actually
set up database backups or or how they
work is probably a more accurate way to
put it so here we've got our production
database
right in everyday new data is being
added to the production database and so
naturally we're concerned right we want
to make sure that even if something
catastrophic happens if this database
gets deleted if some bad code gets
pushed that wipes out all of the rows in
the database right that we have a way to
restore the database so one very common
strategy
is to just kind of snapshot the database
uh let's say daily
a lot of companies I've worked at kind
of just do daily snapshots so for
example
every day at midnight an automated task
runs right there's some code running on
the server that copies all of the data
out of the production database
and into a snapshot for the day so we'd
say prod database copy
you know May 1st 2023
something like that
and and that data
is going to live in cold storage
somewhere it's going to be very cheap
we're going to shove it into a flat file
system we don't need to be able to
access this data kind of live from our
application right so I'm kind of
technically speaking this might live in
something like an Amazon S3 bucket or a
Google a Google Cloud Storage
cloud storage bucket right so very cheap
storage the idea being if something goes
wrong
we can always kind of restore from this
backup back into our prod database right
it's not being used live it's just it's
just a backup and then of course the
next day we would take let me change
colors back
the next day we would take a new
snapshot
and name it
broad database
copy May 2nd 2023 right you get the idea
we're taking snapshots daily and then
usually what would happen is we'd only
keep the snapshots for a certain amount
of time right so we might take a
snapshot every day but only keep them
around for a month so once we have a
month's worth of snapshots we start
deleting the old snapshots just so we
don't need to store all of that data
forever because that could start to get
expensive now you may have already
noticed there's a problem here right if
we're just taking a snapshot every day
that means that we take our snapshot
more data is added to the database and
then something bad happens if we restore
from that last snapshot we're actually
going to lose whatever happened in the
last you know five or six hours since
that snapshot was taken so like the
simple way to solve this or to mitigate
this would be to instead of doing daily
snapshots you could do hourly snapshots
right you still have the same problem
but now you have it at a smaller scale
you'll never lose more than say 59
minutes worth of data now it's worth
pointing out that for most small
companies this snapshot at a you know
hourly or kind of daily rate
um is fine right you hopefully don't
lose your production database anyways
but if you do you're only going to lose
a couple hours of data it's probably not
Mission critical your business probably
won't go out of business right and this
is a very simple thing to set up right
most Cloud providers of databases things
like Amazon RDS or Google Cloud SQL how
have literally just a button you can
click to set up automated snapshots so
if you're working at a small company or
on a small project snapshots are
probably the way to go let's talk about
kind of a more robust option say you
can't afford to lose any data what you
might do in that case
is I mean you'd still have your your
prod let me let me make this a little
bit bigger
you'd still have your prod database but
now instead of taking hourly or daily
snapshots what you might do
is anytime A Change Is enacted on the
prod database
you might set up a system where that
change is copied
to some
to some append Only log append Only log
right so for example if you
create a record here
you would also in the append Only log
the fact that you created the record
similarly if you then delete a record
keep in mind when you delete a record in
the prod database it's just gone poof
right but in the append Only log you
would just log that you deleted a record
so log that record was deleted
the difference is in the append Only log
right we still have
we still have the log of the record
Being created so we could kind of go
back and Replay that record creation
event if we need to so this kind of a
system is frankly a bit more complex to
set up a bit more expensive to set up
um but can give us a little more
granularity and robustness in the sense
that we won't ever lose any real-time
data and I quickly just want to
reiterate the fact that for most
companies especially smaller companies
the snapshot update works just fine and
you'd only kind of venture into this
more complex setup if you really needed
to so we already touched on this briefly
but deleting data can be really really
dangerous right if you delete stuff that
you didn't want to delete uh you'll be
sad right especially you don't have any
sort of backup uh strategy
you know set up so
we've already talked a little bit about
some of the different backup strategies
just know that there's there's really
two high-level things that you want to
think about the first is one make sure
that you have a backup strategy for any
production database right make sure that
you're at least taking snapshots at
regular intervals right so that you know
if something goes catastrophically wrong
today you can at least restore the
database to what it was yesterday yes
some people will lose their data and
that really sucks but it's not as bad as
losing all of the data in the
application for all time so
definitely have some sort of backup
strategy number two is sometimes
you will want to do soft deletes and a
soft delete is just where instead of
taking a snapshot of the entire database
you just never delete stuff from the
database you never run a SQL delete
statement and instead you just Mark
records as deleted right so you have
like a deleted at column on your
database table right and when something
is deleted you'd like set that time
stamp to the time that it was deleted at
and then later when you select data out
in your application logic you just like
ignore stuff that's been marked as
deleted so this this makes it so you
never actually delete anything
um applications do this the only time
you really need to be wary of doing this
I mean there's actually two things the
first is it adds a lot of complexity to
your application because now you have to
actually like be filtering based on this
delete of that flag so it actually is
more more work to do it this way
the other problem is you potentially
have like gdpr or privacy concerns right
because now when your users delete their
accounts their data is not actually
being deleted from every database which
again like from kind of an ethical
privacy standpoint might not be what you
want so just some things to keep in mind
okay the question says you should have
or you should blank have automated
backups uh being taken in a production
database answers are sometimes never
almost never or almost always it's going
to be almost always like please please
have backups
next question says a soft delete is
where you blank
delete some data but it's not actually
removed from the database for 30 days
delete data from a snapshot Mark a row
as deleted instead of actually removing
the data or delete some data by asking
your database in a very nice soothing
voice usually with a please
um it's going to be marking a row as
deleted So Soft delete Market is deleted
don't actually remove the data
one last thing I forgot to say about
soft deletes um
it's just like it can potentially be
expensive in the sense that like if you
have a very large database table and say
like 90 of the data is deleted if you're
keeping it around and just having it
marked as deleted your queries might
start to get slow even though you've
deleted a lot of data so you know soft
deleting will never like make your
database faster due to like decreasing
the amount of data in it so just of
course just another thing to keep in
mind
let's talk about updating data so we've
talked about creating new rows in a
database I'm talking about reading them
we've talked about deleting them now
we're going to talk about updating
existing rows right so maybe we just
want to swap out one specific field or
one specific column on an existing
database Row in SQL we do this with the
update statement so the upstate
statement looks like this update
employees so literally just update and
then the name of the table
set
and then a comma separated list of
column names and their new values
and then an optional where Clause right
so in this case update employees set job
title to backend engineer salary to 150
000 where ID equals 251 right so we're
updating one employee we're giving them
a new title a new salary
great okay let's jump into it with the
assignment says we need to update Lane's
record in our user table he founded
cashpow but he's not even recognized as
an admin update Lane's record within the
users table so that the is admin field
is set to True here's the current state
of the users table
okay so looks like Lane has id9
and currently he is not an admin so
update users
set
what's called is admin true
where
ID equals nine
now
again important to point out here
I could say where a name equals Lane but
if we have other lanes in the database
that we don't want to be admins then
that's going to capture them as well
right so you know be as specific as you
can be with your where Clauses so you
don't run into any of those sorts of
issues let's go ahead and run that
and you can see that the record is
updated so I'll go ahead and submit it I
want to briefly touch on the idea of an
orm an object relational mapping if you
are not new to web development you'll
almost certainly have heard of orms or
maybe even used one before basically the
an RM is just a library that makes it
much easier to interact with a database
and even more specifically the whole
idea of object relational mapping is to
map kind of our in-memory representation
of some object or some struct or some
record
map it to the database schema that we're
using typically the table right so for
example uh we might have in golang a
struct called user and a user has an ID
which an integer a name which is a
string and is admin which is a Boolean
right and this is golang code
right
if we're using an orm
then what we might be able to do is just
create an instance of a user right id10
name Lane is admin false and use some
sort of method or function like
database.create give it the user and it
will just kind of automatically generate
the SQL that will run that insert
statement right so generate an insert
statement and execute it against the
database this is really convenient right
because it means we don't have to
worry about writing all of the raw SQL
we can kind of automatically map objects
in our programming language to rows in
our databases
um there are good and bad things about
RMS I would argue that generally
speaking you'll want to use an orm as
long as the orm makes it easy to also
write straight SQL
right so you still get this escape hatch
where you can do very specific and very
I don't want to say complex but more
advanced things with your SQL right
sometimes very simple functions like
create update delete
um will get you really far
but later you'll need to write more
complex queries right things that we'll
cover later in this course and if your
orm is limiting you from using the full
flexibility or the full power of SQL as
a language then that can be a
disadvantage so
um
to to like sum up and give you a rule of
thumb and orm typically trades
Simplicity for control and again in
production what that often means is you
will use an orm for most stuff and then
occasionally you'll need to write some
some raw SQL when you're trying to do
something very very specific
cool the question here is when using an
orm you blank
call methods and functions made
available via the orms API or you write
a lot of raw SQL and the answer is you
call methods and functions made
available from the orms API next
question says one advantage of an orm is
that it blank gives you more control
over your database is easier to debug at
a low level makes your code less verbose
or ensures faster queries
this isn't actually this is actually
interesting the answer is that it makes
your code less verbose right you don't
have to write nearly as much code when
you're using an orm you just call some
function or some method that's been
rebuilt for you by the library
um so it does make your code less
verbose however I do want to point out
that it does not give you more control
over your database in some cases it
actually takes control away it's also
not easier to debug at a low level
because if you want to figure out what
SQL is being run against your database
from this method you're going to have to
do some digging right rather than just
looking at your code and you know fixing
your SQL
also insurers faster queries again not
necessarily the case sometimes
especially when your orm code starts to
get a little hairy it can really
generate inefficient SQL which again can
be hard to debug so there's trade-offs
with orms I'm definitely not going to
say they're bad or they're good use as
intended so should you use an orm almost
always it depends on the project team
almost never always I'm gonna go with it
depends on the project slash team there
are instances where an orm makes a ton
of sense and there are instances where
it doesn't
moving on let's talk about aliases so
there is an as keyword a-s as in SQL
that allows us to essentially rename
different words in our SQL queries and
we would typically do this to make the
query a little bit more concise easier
to type less verbose and it's important
to understand that these aliases they
only last for the duration of the query
so really the convenience they provide
is just for kind of within the SQL
itself it doesn't persist it doesn't get
saved to the database or anything like
that it's really just to make writing
the query itself a little simpler let me
show you an example so let's pretend
that we have two columns employee ID and
employee name on an employee's table now
first of all I would argue that this
naming scheme isn't very good I would
have preferred to just see an ID column
and a name column because remember these
columns are on the IDS table so it's
pretty obvious that it's an employee I
ID and an employee name so you kind of
have some redundancy here in the column
names but either way let's just assume
that this is the schema we're working
with what we can do is Alias the
employee ID column as just ID in the
employee name column as just name now it
does two things it means that later in
the query we can refer to those columns
as just ID and name right so it makes
writing the SQL a little simpler it also
means that when the data comes back from
the database like the literal rows that
we get back from the database the keys
for those columns will now be ID and
name instead of employee ID and employee
name so kind of useful from a
structuring the return data standpoint
as well so let's see what this looks
like in an actual assignment let's write
some code says a user has asked us to
find all the transactions on their
account from their Grandma we thought it
would be fun to rename the note field to
birthday message because we noticed all
the transactions from Grandma just
happened to be birthday messages return
the amount and the note field renamed to
birthday message from the transactions
table where the sender ID is 10 which is
Grandma okay I'm going to show the
database setup code so we can see what
we're working with here
all right so return the amount and the
note field so select
amount
from
transactions
where
sender ID equals 10. now if I just run
this as is
this is what I get right the key for
this column is amount the key for this
column is note and then we've got the
amounts we've got the notes
but we've been asked to rename the note
field to birthday message so we'll do
note as birthday
[Music]
message
and now the only difference here again
well I should say there's two
differences this now means that later in
the query we can refer to the note
column as birthday message but we're not
going to do that because we don't care
in this query right we don't need to use
we don't need to like write a where
Clause using the note column so we don't
have to worry about that but what it
should do is also change that key in the
return data right so now when we parse
these SQL rows in our application we'll
parse this column as birthday message
cool I'm going to go ahead and submit
that let's talk about functions in SQL
so remember that SQL is a language and
like most programming language it
supports functions right so in SQL
functions look very similar to functions
that you've used in other programming
languages and would you call them you
use parentheses and you pass in some
number of arguments right so in this
case we've got the iif function
open parentheses to start passing in
parameters and then we're passing in one
two three parameters and then we're
closing the function call now you might
be wondering what the iif function does
well the iif function is essentially a
ternary if you're familiar with turn
areas from JavaScript and basically what
it says is
first give me a condition if the
condition is true
I will return the first value you give
me but if the TR if the condition is
false I'll return the second value right
and actually if you look closely there's
actually a slight bug here because if
these two values are the same
then it will return the string car B is
bigger so this would probably say car B
is greater than or equal to
something like that anyways uh
irrelevance the point is uh you get how
this works right conditions true we
return the first thing conditions false
we return the second thing so iif can be
really useful if we're trying to like
compute something based on some
conditional so when would I use this
kind of a function well let's take a
look at the example
let's say we have a products table
and we want to return kind of how many
we have of each product right so say
we've got I don't know 10 apples and 30
Bananas in stock right let's return the
the sheer amount that we have but we
also want to return
a little text string that that's a
little more descriptive right that can
be computed from the quantity itself so
in this case we're saying if the
quantity is less than 10 we're also
going to return the string or also going
to put in the return Row the string
order more
otherwise if we have at least 10 we're
going to put the string in stock in the
row and you can see why this would be
really useful right now you can give
your employee this report and it will
just clearly State on every row right
apples nine order more right bananas 11
in stock now they can just take a look
at the order more or the in stock column
to see whether or not they should order
more of whatever it is right we can do
interesting kind of computed columns in
our return data by using a function like
this and you can see we're actually
coupling this with an as with an as
clause
so that when the data comes back it has
a nice kind of column name to it so the
assignment for this lesson says we need
to look through cash Pals transaction
data and determine whether or not any of
the transactions need to be audited
return all the data from the
transactions table and add an extra
column at the end called audit okay so
let's just let's just start with that so
select
star from
that right from transactions
and add an extra column name at the end
called audit so if I just run this query
I'll just get the whole transactions
table
okay
now this audit column it says if a rows
was successful field is true the audit
field should say no transact no action
required however if one successful is
false the audit field should say perform
an audit okay so
in addition to the Wilds card in
addition to everything else we're also
going to return
um a new column we're calling it audit
and in order to calculate the audit
field we're going to use this iif it's
iif not iff right okay iif
and the condition is going to be if was
successful
equals
true
right or actually I think because this
evaluates to a Boolean we can just say
if was successful
so if was successful is true then the
first thing we pass in as a parameter
technically the second parameter right
the first thing after the condition
um will be what's return so we'll do no
action
required
otherwise
we'll say perform and
audit
and then we want this new column to be
called
audit
so select star and audit
and the way we'll calculate audit
is using this function right so in
theory we should have one
row down here at the bottom right this
magic the Gathering draft row it should
be the only one where an audit needs to
be performed so let's run that again
take a look at our results set
yep no action required on all of those
perform an audit on the last one this
looks good to me another useful Clause
is the between Clause right so this
essentially lets us to check whether a
value is between two other values right
so in this example select employee name
and salary from the employees table
where the salary is between thirty
thousand and sixty thousand right so
we'll go get all the rows from the
database where the salary field has a
value between Thirty and sixty thousand
it's also worth pointing out that we can
just throw a knot before the between and
that will give us everything that's not
between the two numbers right so if we
don't want everything between 20 and 100
then we can do a not between oh the
assignment says we need to figure out or
we need to see how many young adults are
using cash pal query our users table to
find all the name and age fields of
users between the ages of 13 and 18.
seems straightforward enough so select
name age
ROM
capitalize from users
where
age between
oops
18.
and
30.
cool let's run that
this is looking good
let me see what the full I'm actually
curious now what does the full table
look like
run run without between
yeah okay so we're like excluding Ram
here
excluding David
cool okay
that looks right to me let's submit it
distinct is another Super useful keyword
that does kind of what you'd expect it
allows us to select rows where a
distinct value is present so for example
select distinct previous company from
employees this will only return one row
her unique value right so let's say that
I have 10 employees and between the 10
employees maybe there's three that
worked at Google four that worked at
Microsoft and another three that works
at Apple when I run this query I only
expect to get three values back Apple
Google Microsoft so jumping into the
assignment it says cash Bell Executives
want to know how many countries we have
customers in we store country code data
as a column on the users table run a
distinct query to get all the unique
country codes from the users table so
simple enough
select
entry
ode I'm going to run it kind of the
normal way first so we can see the
difference from
let me capitalize that from users
select country code from users if I just
run this
I'll get one country code per Row in the
database you can see tons of stuff here
but this isn't what the executive is
asking for right they don't want a
single Row for every user in the
database maybe we have a hundred
thousand users right they just want to
know how many countries total
right exist across all of our users so
we can use distinct
distinct
run that again
oh
I had to refresh my page
had a network issue okay
so it's like this to cover good now yeah
now we get it uh kind of whittled down
to each unique country code I'm going to
go ahead and submit that
let's talk about logical operators
you're probably already familiar with
logical operators if you've done any
sort of programming in like python or
JavaScript or whatever it's really
simple in SQL The Logical operators are
just the keywords and and or spoiler
alert we'll talk about or in just a
second
cool so when we're writing for example a
where clause
we can add more than one condition
by ending that condition with another
condition so for example here we're
selecting product name quantity shipment
status right those three columns from
the products table where both of these
things are true the shipment status is
pending and the quantities between 0 and
10. right
this again should be pretty uh pretty a
pretty familiar concept if you've done
any sort of programming before
um and then in the the only thing I
really want to call attention to in SQL
is that when you're doing equality in
SQL all these inequality operators are
what you'd expect right less than
greater than less than or equal to
greater than or equal to
um but the equal operator when you're
checking for equality is just a single
equals it's not double equals or triple
equals like it is in some other
languages
um and and that's just because it's not
taken up for assignment so uh it like
it's not taken up as the assignment
operator so it's just just the equal
sign
cool like you could see here right
shipment status equals pending not
equals equals pending
okay with all that Preamble let's get to
the assignment it says the legal
restrictions in Canada have changed the
way that we handle uh Canadian miners so
miners are people under the age of 18
right essentially kids
um the way that we handle their
transactions has to be more strict right
for legal reasons we need to find all
those users so we can find how many of
our users are going to be affected by
these changes so write a query that
retrieves all of the fields from the
users table
where the users are from Canada and are
under the age of 18.
we can take a look at the table here
okay
select star
from users
where
country
code equals Canada
and
age
says under the age of 18. so less than
18.
run that
this looks good to me
now we're going to work with the or
operator so it works very similarly to
the and operator but instead of both
conditions on either side of the or
keyword needing to evaluate to True only
one does right so
and to be clear it's okay if both do so
at least one side needs to evaluate to
True at least one condition needs to
evaluate to true and it's also worth
pointing out that the order of
operations can be manipulated with
parentheses so in this case we're saying
we're going to evaluate this and that
first
and then the result of that
is going to be ored with the other right
so we can use parentheses
um just like in math uh to adjust the
order of operations
okay assignment says the laws have
changed again now we need to see how
many affected users meet this criteria
users who are from the United States or
Canada and are under 18. write a query
that retrieves the count of every user
that matches the conditions okay so
select
count
star
ROM users let's just run that
so in total there's 11 users in our
table
next we need to filter this down and say
where
country
code equals US
or country code equals Canada
okay with that filtering we're down to
eight
now I'm going to pop this in
in parentheses and say and because we're
requiring that
all the users must be under 18 and age
is less than 18.
let's run that
perfect
next we've got the in Clause
um this one's pretty cool and it's not
always in my opinion super intuitive how
it works so we'll definitely go over it
um but basically the in operator returns
true or false if the first operand
matches any of the values in the second
operand so it's kind of a shorthand for
like multiple or conditions so take a
look at this we've got this first query
select product name and shipment status
from the products table where shipment
status is in
this kind of list of options so as long
as shipment status is one of these
shipping preparing or out of stock it
will return true which means we'll
return the row right whereas here we've
got select product name shipment status
from products where shipment status is
shipped or shipment status is preparing
or shipment status is out of stock these
are identical queries they do the exact
same thing this is just kind of a more
convenient way to write it and later
we'll see how this allows us to kind of
use the in operator with Dynamic data so
we don't have to like explicitly spell
out all of the different options right
maybe we're comparing against other data
that's somewhere else in the database
cool
so
um let's jump into the assignment it
says we want to know which of our users
are from North America right a select
statement that Returns the name age and
country code fields for every user
within us Canada or Mexico
so
select this isn't account right we want
to know which of our users
yeah okay so select name age
country
code
ROM users
where
C A not age where country code
in
us
Canada
Mexico
looks good to me I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna send it on this one
next we've got the like operator I love
the like operator it's kind of the first
operator that we've used that allows for
like fuzzy matching right or kind of
wild card matching so the first thing to
understand is that the like keyword is
going to allow us to look stuff up in
the database by like partial matches
right so uh
we'll get to that it'll make more sense
with an example
um first let me explain this uh kind of
percent operator so this percent sign
operator will match zero or more
characters and we can use this operator
within the query string
that's supplied to the like clause
to find more than just exact matches
depending on where we place it so for
example
select starfront products where product
name is like this string right banana
percent
and what we're saying is
any product names that just start with
the string banana we want to match right
because this this percent sign
effectively says anything else can be
here right zero or more characters uh
can can be in in this spot in the string
so similarly if we want every product
name that ends in banana we just put the
percent at the beginning right and then
if we just want to do a contains right
does the string banana show up anywhere
in the product name then we can just
slap a percent sign on both sides of the
string so the assignment says our HR
team is dealing with a ticket from one
of our users but they're having a
trouble pulling up their record in the
database they're pretty sure the
username starts with a l write a query
that returns all the fields for records
where the user's name starts with Al
okay so select
star
ROM users
where
the name
is like
say starts so starts with also it needs
to be a l
and then percent
cool
I'm gonna just send it
right we got Alan Albert Alvin Alphonse
looks good to me so still working with
the like claws we're going we're going
to take a look at another operator
basically so the the percent operator or
the percent sign
um like I said matches zero or more
characters whereas the underscore
operator matches exactly one character
right so for example here we are saying
uh you know give me all
products where the product name is a
four letter word that ends in oot right
so it'll match boot root foot
here I don't know if you can tell but
there's actually two underscores but now
this is going to match things like shoot
and Groot but importantly it will not
match things like boot root and Foot
Right explicitly going to have five
characters
okay
HR has been able to narrow down their
query even further they want a report of
all users whose names start with Al and
are exactly five characters long Okay so
let's do select
star from users
where
name
like
underscore underscore
underscore
put an L at the beginning so it starts
with Al
one two three underscores
run that
Alan and Alvin perfect and just to show
you what would have happened if we did
this
we would match some more stuff we'd get
Alfonso and Albert
so that's looking right to me
first quiz question dealing with wild
cards and the like the like Clause says
which describes the values that match
example one okay so this is example one
or underscore
wild card
let's see values that start with or yep
and have three characters exactly no
because we've got this wild card here
that could be zero or more characters
values that end in or nope that's not it
values that end in or no that's not it
values that start with or and are at
least three characters in length yeah
that's accurate right we need three
characters we could have some more next
question which would not match example
two
so we've got two underscores here
bling that matches sling that matches
thing that matches singing does not
match too many characters right this
this only has room for five characters
new keyword we've got the limit keyword
now
this one this might be one of the
keywords that I use the absolute most in
SQL apart from like the obvious things
like select and where
um limit is super super common both when
you're writing application code as well
as when you're just kind of making
one-off queries to a database because
it's very often the case that when
you're working on a production scale
database a table doesn't just have six
or seven or ten rows like what we've
been dealing with in our little sandbox
environment right we could have a
thousand rows we could have a million
rows we could have 100 million rows in
the database and if you try to just
select all of those rows something's
going to crash right that's a lot of
data to pull out of a database all at
once so that's where the limit keyword
becomes really really useful
here's what it looks like so after any
select statement we can end it with this
limit this limit section here we're
saying just give me 50. do not give me
more than 50 rows right give me up 250.
so if my query was only going to you
know return three rows anyways the limit
keyword effectively would do nothing
here but if like you know seven thousand
products match this query
we're going to stop the database and say
just give me the first 50. it's gonna be
the first 50.
okay
moving on to the assignment says a lot
of our users have been using cashpile to
pay other users for lunch let's take a
look at a sample of that data write a
query that returns all rows and Fields
from the transactions table
any record where the note field has the
word lunch in it okay and the query
should return at most five records so
select
uh it says all rows and Fields yeah
select star from
transactions
where
note like
just has the word lunch so we'll do wild
cards on either side so lunch
okay
and let's just go ahead and run that
really quick to see how many there are
looks like we've got a lot
14.
and now we'll limit it
down to just the first five
cool just five just Five results now
I want to just point out you'll probably
do this a lot when you're like manually
working with a database and just try to
like figure out what the data sort of
looks like right so you've got a
database we've got a table in it maybe
it has a hundred thousand records you
don't need to see every single record to
get a feel for like what all the columns
are and what kind of data is actually in
those columns you'd typically just kind
of like connect to the database run a
simple query like this maybe limit it to
10 or 20 or 30 rows that you can fairly
easily scan through that's something I
find myself doing a lot as a back-end
developer
cool I'm gonna go ahead and submit that
so this question here says limit five
will always return five records
and the answers are true and false and
the reason this is false I'll just go
ahead and click that now the reason this
is false is because if the query we're
only going to return 0 or 1 or 2 records
anyways then limit five isn't going to
add records right it's just saying don't
give me more than five so it's actually
possible for a query with limit five on
the end to return
fewer than five records
next question says why might you use a
limit clause
first answer I wouldn't system
performance is an Ops person's problem
I like that answer but it's wrong uh
next one is to get as much data as
possible
nope that can't be it right we're trying
to limit the data the amount of data
because I'm a machine learning engineer
and don't care about efficiency again
kind of funny not accurate last one to
avoid selecting a huge amount of data
and causing strain on the system it's
going to be that last one
next is the order by clause and this one
usually goes hand in hand with the limit
Clause it's very often that you'll use
both of these in a query and it's
because the order by Clause allows us to
sort the data right and then the limit
Clause caps the amount of data right so
if we order it the way we want it and
then we just get like the first five
that's that's potentially pretty useful
right like give me for example like
maybe you're building a leaderboard haha
a leaderboard right like the one we have
on boot Dev and uh I want to like get
all of the users but I first I want to
sort them by like how many exercises
they've completed right and then just
give me the top ten like that's a very
common type of query that you're going
to make in a database so let's take a
look at an example so here we've got you
know select name price quantity from
products order by price
this is going to sort by the price field
now by default it's going to sort in
ascending order right in other words
it's going to put the lowest values at
the top and then go down from there
right
whereas or sorry it's going to put the
lowest values at the top and then
increase in value as you go down row by
row that's ascending order right if you
want descending order you have to
explicitly specify it right so order by
quantity descending right
um and that would again that would give
us the highest values at the top and
then the values would drop as we go down
okay so the assignment says write a
query that lists all the records in the
transactions table where amount is
between 10 to 80 and the results are
sorted by amount in descending order
okay so first let's just write the
select statement so select
star from transactions
where amount
between
10 and 80. okay let's just run that
take a look
so we've got our data
correct but it's not ordered the way we
want right the amounts are kind of all
all out of order
so we'll add
order by
what was it amount order by amount if I
run this
so now we've got the smallest amount at
the top and it's ascending as we go down
but it says we want it in descending
order so we want the biggest amount at
the top so we'll just add a descending
keyword there run that
cool now we've got the biggest amounts
at the top and we go down from there
all right we've got a quiz got a little
database table here it says example one
is sorted in blank order and I'm going
to go ahead and assume it's talking
about the age column
much more obvious how to sort by age and
then sort by name
um
it's sorted in descending order right we
start with the biggest number we go down
from there next Quiz question says which
query would potentially return the data
in example one okay same table says
select star from people order by age
that would not give us this data because
it doesn't specify an order so it would
do ascending so that that wouldn't do it
select star from people order by age
descending that could definitely be it
ascending again no and select star from
people order by descending age that
one's just incorrect
so it's going to be ordered by age
descending all right now we're going to
use both of these uh keywords kind of in
tandem like I said earlier this is
pretty common
assignment says an HR employee got into
the git repository where we store all of
the queries that we run and try to
update one himself
fix the bug in the SQL query okay
so select star from transactions where
amount between 10 and 80 limit for order
by amount descending
let's try to run that
SQL logic error right
the problem here so this wasn't actually
a problem I just it just bothered me the
descending is in lower case and I like I
like my conventional SQL where
where everything's capitalized
um
the problem here is that these are out
of order you need to order by first
first we sort
then we truncate is like the way I like
to think about it first you sort the
data set and then you limit it down to
just the bit that you want so let's run
that
aggregations are one of my favorite
Parts about working with databases now
aggregation sounds like a big scary word
but it's actually a pretty simple
concept an aggregation is just when we
take a large amount of raw data and
aggregate it down into a single value
now there's something interesting that I
want to point out when it comes to
architecting your database generally
speaking I think it's a really good idea
to store database or store data in your
database in sort of a raw format and the
reason for that is if you pre-aggregate
your data right if you pre-compute a
result and then store it in your
database and say kind of discard the
original raw data you can never get back
at that original kind of raw form of the
data so generally speaking it's a good
idea to store data in your database in
sort of a raw format and then you can
just run aggregation queries on the fly
when you need the calculated data and I
know I'm talking in vagaries but we're
going to hop into to it in just a second
so you can really see what I mean so
without realizing it you've probably
well you actually have already written
an aggregation in s
function is a very simple aggregation
right it takes as input many rows from
the database and returns a single value
right the count of how many rows there
are so to sort of reiterate why this
matters right why we would store data in
a raw format and just run for example
account query when we want to know the
count of rows is if we just store the
count of rows thinking well maybe I
don't actually need all these
transactions I need to store the count
of transactions because at the moment
all I'm doing is showing on the page how
many transactions they are
problem is if later down the line we
need to show something like when the
transactions happened right so we need
all the dates on every individual
transaction if all we were doing was
storing the results of the aggregation
the count itself we wouldn't be able to
go backwards so again I just want to
reiterate store data in a raw format
right as raw as you can as raw as makes
sense and run aggregations like count
queries
when you need that data so let's hop
into the assignment says the front-end
team is building a dashboard page in
cash pal we need to be able to provide
them the number of successful
transactions for a given user return the
number of transactions where the user ID
is six and was successful is true
okay so select
count
star
now remember when we're using the count
we're using the count function
this this wild card refers to the fields
right so we're just saying we don't care
which field we count we just care about
the number of total rows so just keep
that in mind all right select count of
star
um
from
section transactions
[Music]
where
let's see user ID equals six
and was successful
true
cool
let's try running that
we got three
let's take a look at the setup code just
so we can see okay yeah it looks like a
lot of stuff was inserted into the
database so we sh it looks like we're
filtering it down
um kind of to an appropriate amount I'm
going to go ahead and just submit that
moving on we've got another aggregation
this is one that we have not used yet so
the sum function or the sum aggregation
does what you'd expect it sums a group
of values now with the sum aggregation
it wouldn't make sense to use all of the
fields in a database right we're not
counting rows now what we're trying to
do is sum all of the values in an
individual column so here we're going to
pass in the salary field as the
parameter to the sum aggregation in
order to get a total so let's jump into
the assignment it says we need to be
able to calculate the current balance
for a given user because we don't yet
store the running balance on each
individual transaction record write a
query that Returns the sum aggregation
of the amounts for all of Bob's
transactions
so first let's just go ahead and do
select
star ROM
transactions transactions
where user
ID equals nine right for Bob let's just
take a look at this data
okay so it looks like there's three
transactions and we've got three amounts
10 50 50 and negative 24.89
now to get his balance all we have to do
is sum
the amount field
for the amount column right
go ahead and run that
cool that looks about right based on
what I remember from Bob's transactions
we've got another aggregation to
practice with this is the max
aggregation again pretty obvious what it
does it just Returns the largest value
from a set of values so for example
select Max price from products should
return the product the max price or
specifically the value of the max price
so
let's jump into the assignment again
pretty straightforward how this works so
I want to just get right to an example
it says use a Max aggregation to find
the largest amount of money received by
Jill user ID for return her user ID and
that amount okay so
first I want to just find the
transactions uh from Jill so select star
from
friends actions
where user E equals four
okay
run that
get a feel for what Jill's transactions
look like
okay and we're looking for the max find
the largest amount of money
return her user ID and that amount okay
so it looks like the max is 50 so we're
going to expect that so I want to do
select Max
amount
and I can just comma separate right
because I want to select multiple things
select a max amount and user ID
from transactions
run that
yep 50. there it is perfect
we did Max time to zoom in Min function
works the exact same way except it
Returns the lowest value smallest value
okay assignment says use a Min
aggregation to find the age of our
youngest cash pal user in the United
States in the users table
okay the users table has these fields
available to it ID name age country code
username okay
um and we want
just the age okay so select
Min h
ROM
oh this is from the users table from
users
where
country code equals US
run that
that looks right to me
now let's talk about the group by Clause
so the group by Clause is not an
aggregation function like Min or Max but
instead it gives us a more powerful way
to interact with aggregation functions
let me show you what I mean
so the group by Clause essentially
allows us to create multiple summary
rows in other words to kind of run the
aggregation multiple times resulting in
multiple results so for example
look at this query we've got select
album ID and the count of song IDs so
give me the album and the number of
songs
in the songs table
grouped by the album ID
right this is a really useful query
we've got a huge list of songs they all
have album IDs on those records we can
group all the rows for each album ID
together and count the number of songs
right super useful query a way to see
how many songs are in each album let's
use it in the assignment says let's get
the balance of every user now all in a
single query use a combination of the
sum aggregation and the group by Clause
to return a single Row for each user the
row for each user should contain the
user ID and their balance which is a sum
of their amounts called balance so we
want to make sure we Alias that column
so that it's called balance okay
so
select user ID
sum
amount
ROM
this is transactions
where wait is there a where here use
combination no ROM transactions Group by
user ID
use a combination of the summary by
files single Row for each user okay that
looks right the rush contain the user ID
and their balance okay cool oh we just
need to we need to Alias it so let me
run it like this
and you can see by default SQL just kind
of gives us uh some amount as the name
of this column which is kind of nasty
we're going to do instead as a balance
like that
and submit that next we've got the
average aggregation again it does
exactly what you'd imagine these are
kind of various uh common statistics
ideas right we're going to find the
average of a bunch of values it is
important to note that it does ignore
null value so it's only going to average
kind of the values that exist
cool
let's use it in the assignment it says
our marketing team is trying to
determine the best marketing channels to
advertise through but they need more
information about our current users they
wish to know the average age of users in
the United States return a single value
representing the average age of all
users where the country code is us so
select average age
from users where country
code equals US
let's just send it
we got it let's talk about the having
clause and I actually want you to almost
pause the video well not positive well
okay pause the video after I explain
this concept because it's one of those
Concepts that when I first learned about
databases really eluded me I had a
really hard time understanding the
difference between the having clause and
the where Clause so let me try to break
it down for you
the having Clause is just like the where
Clause it works the same way it's used
to filter rows down the difference
is that having operates on rows after an
aggregation has taken place due to like
a group by Clause right whereas the
where Clause operates on the rows before
the aggregation happens
does that make sense so if you think
about the order in which the query is
kind of executed first the where Clause
is going to filter the total result set
down to some smaller set then the group
by Clause is going to kind of break that
smaller set into individual groups that
you can then aggregate right like maybe
you can get the count of all songs in
the album right you've got five albums
you've got five subgroups
the having Clause allows you to filter
again
after that group by using the results of
the group by in the having Clause so to
be clear the having Clause is definitely
not as commonly used as the where Clause
right because it's only really going to
be used in tandem with an aggregation
let's take a look at this example
so here we have select album ID count of
ID as count
s Group by album ID so we've seen this
before right this should return the
album ID and the number of songs in the
album
the difference now is that we've added a
having count is greater than five Clause
so what this will do is it will take
that end result right of album ID and
count
let's say that there were 10 albums each
with their own kind of song Count
associated with them
on that small resulting set of the 10
albums with their counts we're going to
filter one last time where we remove all
of the rows or all of the albums
essentially that don't have at least
five songs in them as usual hopefully
this makes more sense after the
assignment let's jump right into it
says a new page in the cash Pal app
allows users to see how much money
they've spent on a specific kind of
transaction and alerts them if that
amount is fairly large let's write a
query that Returns the total amount
spent by each user on lunch when that
balance is greater than 20. okay so this
is actually going to be a pretty
complex query which is which is great
good for practice right again
um if you're following Along on boot Dev
highly recommend you pause the video and
try to solve this on your own
so it says your query should return a
sender ID the person's spending the
money at a balance
the balance is the sum of all amounts
spent so first let's just let's just
start by getting a look into this table
um we're working with the transactions
table I believe let me in fact let me go
ahead and take a look at the setup code
yeah it's just a bunch of transactions
so to start let's just select
star from transactions
take a look at some of this data
okay now we can kind of start to
understand what we're working with
so we want a query that Returns the
total amount spent by each user so it's
going to look something like this
selects select sum amount
from transactions
Group by
user ID
and I should probably include the user
ID there is that something we want
return a sender ID the person spending
the money and a balance the balance is
the sum of all the amounts spent it's
going to be some amount as balance
run that so now we can see the user site
the user IDs and their balances
total amount spent by each user on lunch
when that balance is greater than 20.
okay so we also need a having
balance greater than 20 so we'll filter
out any rows that don't have that it's
now really starting to get down into the
weeds here
says the query should return a sender ID
the person spending the money okay so we
don't actually want the user ID we want
the sender ID
which means I think we should be
grouping by the sender ID as well don't
return any rows that have a null sender
ID yeah so we want to group by the
sender ID
the note must contain the word lunch to
be part of the aggregation so that's
actually a where Clause right so
where
note like we know how to do this right
like
percent lunch
percent right that'll match a zero or
more characters
let's run that okay now we're really
getting somewhere got three Center IDs
we got some balances
order the results by the balance in
ascending order
order by balance ascending
okay we did we check all these boxes
returning the sender ID and a balance
good
the balance is the sum of the amounts
good don't return any rows that have a
null sender ID there's no nulls there
Group by sender ID yup the note must
contain lunch we got that
the aggregated get balance must be
greater than 20. we got that
order the results by balance in
ascending order we should be good to go
I know I already went over this but I
really just want to reiterate it again
because this can be really confusing
the difference between the having and
where Clauses because they are very
similar they're both used to filter down
result set is that the where condition
is applied to all the rows before the
rows are grouped into aggregate rows
right whereas the halving condition is
applied to the group throws right the
results of the aggregations so with that
in mind let's look at the question it
says in the example should you use a
where clause or a having Clause to
filter down to a specific class ID so
here's the example
select class ID account ID as count from
students wear blank group by class ID
having blank
so if we want to filter down to a
specific class ID
we should actually do that in the where
Clause because we have access to that
information before doing the group by
right
having is is typically used to filter
based on the result sets so we would do
that after the aggregation so in this
case we'll use the where next question
says in the example should you use a
wearer or a having Clause to filter down
classes of a particular size okay
interesting so this is the the count
right the size is the count of students
in a class
we can't do that before the group by
Clause because we haven't yet figured
out the count in inside each of each
class right we have to do the
aggregation on each class ID to figure
out how many rows right how many student
rows there are for each individual class
so it has to actually be the having the
having uh clause in this case let's talk
about rounding numbers not every
function that's built into SQL is an
aggregation right the round function is
not an aggregation it takes just a
single value as input well technically
it takes two values right it takes the
value to be rounded and the Precision
that we want to round the value to but
it is really common to use the round
function when you're dealing with the
results of an aggregation and by default
if we do not pass in a value for the
Precision parameter by default SQL will
just round it to the nearest whole
number at least SQL light will okay so
the assignment says fixed query so it
returns a whole number
that just means a number without a
fractional part right and rename the
result column to round age okay so first
let's just run this as is we get this
really nasty decimal point here
we're going to change this to
round to a whole number I would expect
this to round up to 28 right
yep 28 that looks good and then it says
to rename this field this is a nasty
nasty column name right round average
age disgusting let's Alias it as
round age
perfect
fair warning the queries we write in
this chapter will start to get a little
bit harder we're moving into sub queries
so make sure that you understand regular
queries at least all the concepts we've
covered so far fairly well before moving
on to this chapter let's take a look at
an example so in this query we've got
select ID song name artist ID from the
songs table where the artist ID is in
now remember we've seen the in keyword
before we kind of used it to select uh
or to query for when a value is in a
list or a a set of values but now
instead of saying for example artist ID
in you know one two or three right a
list of explicit IDs we're going to
perform a sub query inside of these
parentheses and we're saying we want the
artist ID to be in the res result set of
this sub query
right so this query will run first and
the results
will be used here in the in Clause
hopefully that makes sense it should
make some more sense when we get to
writing some code here in a second and I
do want to point out that actually the
only
syntax specific to sub queries are these
parentheses that surround the sub query
itself right we're we're quite literally
just writing a normal query and using
the result set here in this in statement
so jumping down into the assignment it
says one of cashpow's customer service
Representatives needs us to pull all the
transactions for a specific user the
trouble is they only know the user's
name not the user's ID so keep in mind
we could solve this problem by like
running a query to get the user by their
name copying the ID and then manually
running a second query what using a sub
query is going to allow us to do is do
it all at once all in one SQL query so
we've been tasked with using a sub query
to get all of David's transactions okay
so we want to select
star from
transactions
where
user ID
equals now remember we weren't provided
with a user ID so we actually can't
explicitly set it here
so we need to use subquery where user ID
equals
select
ID
from users
where
they go to another line
where name equals
David
okay
we can just double check does this match
our syntax from before
looks good
okay so to be clear we've got two
different tables we're interacting with
a transactions table and a users table
and we are saying we want to get all the
transactions
for the user whose ID is
whatever the results of this query is
which is Select ID from users where
David equals where name equals David
whoo okay let's go ahead and run that
that looks good to me it looks like it's
grabbing all the records for user id1
let's just check the setup code really
quick and make sure that
uh David is number one it looks like he
is because we're using an auto increment
primary key ID so David should be
ID number one
cool I'm gonna submit now I just want to
point out the difference between the
query we wrote in the example here like
I said before the in syntax is not
required for sub queries the difference
is that in this query we expect multiple
rows or multiple values to be returned
so we need to do an in Clause whereas
here we expected just a single user to
be returned and in fact if we wanted to
ensure that we could add a
limit one right just in case there are
multiple Davids next we've got a little
quiz
so it says a sub query
a creates a temporary table B allows you
to query the result set of a nested
query or C is a technique for speeding
up your database now it doesn't create a
temporary table a subquery only exists
at execution time so no data is actually
stored in the database like the result
set of your sub query is not stored in a
new table in the database or a temporary
table in the database that's not what's
happening
it's it's just a way to express a subset
or a result set within your query it
only exists at execution time
um and it's not a technique for speeding
up your database it's it's not any sort
of like performance optimization at
least not inherently so the answer is it
allows you to query the result set of a
nested query
now this quiz question says the example
will return blank rows
okay let's take a look at this we've got
select ID song name artist ID from songs
where artist ID in
okay this is actually the same example
from the previous lesson
how many rows
will this return
well
we can expect
that this sub query will return multiple
rows because it's just querying for
names like Rick so anyone with a first
name last name combo that starts with
Rick is going to be returned here
right and then the outer query
is selecting ID song name artist ID from
the songs table
so it's potentially selecting many songs
where the artist is in this smaller list
of artists so I mean we're already
working with multiple artists so it
stands to reason that we have to be
working with multiple songs so
potentially many is what I'm going to go
with here it's important to remember
that
that well is
nickly a full programming language now
like I said at the beginning of the
course we don't typically use SQL to
build Out full applications from scratch
right it is a domain specific language
in the sense that it's intended to be a
query language a language used to
interact with databases but it is a
programming language right it has
functions it has ways to do these sorts
of things one example of this is that
you can actually select information
using SQL
without having any backing database or
table so for example this query select 5
plus 10 as sum I mean all that does in
fact I'll just run it here
all that does is return a sum column
with the result 15 right but you'll
notice I didn't even reference any
tables in order to do that let's jump
into the assignment that kind of
demonstrates this so the finance
department has found that people who
have lived longer than 40 years need to
start thinking about retirement write a
query that returns all of the users who
are more than 40 years old
unfortunately this tapered awkwardly
stores age in days in the age and days
field use a sub query to convert years
to days and filter on that assume every
year has 365 days okay
so write a query that returns all the
users for more than 40 years old select
star from users
where
let's say age
this age is greater than something like
this then we'll do a sub query there
now we have an age in days field
where age is greater than
we can do
age in days
sorry we want to reference age and days
because that's that's the actual column
that's on the database right yeah okay
oops so agent days
is greater than now remember we can't
just do 40 here
we can't just do that because that's
years so we need to convert to days
so we can do
is 40
times 365.
right we'll convert our years into days
cool let's run that and see what we get
see these age and dates values are
actually quite large that looks good to
me
another quiz SQL can only operate on
data stored in tables that is false as
we just saw
architecting a database can be really
tricky but the most important thing to
get right is that you've modeled your
one-to-one relationships your one to
many and your many-to-many relationships
accurately if you do that everything
else will start to fall into place let's
talk about so there are really three
different types of relationships that we
can have between entities in our
database
right we've got
one to one one to many
and many to many
and to draw that out
looks something like this if I have one
of entity number one it relates to one
thing of entity number two
another thing of NC number one it
relates to exactly one other thing of NC
number two
you get the idea
right one to many would look more like
this we have some some things of type
number one or of entity number one and
they might relate to
three
different types
of entity number two
the second one might relate to two
this third one might just relate to one
right it's really one two zero to many
right we might even have one that
doesn't relate uh to anything there
okay cool and then a many-to-many
relationship is exactly what it sounds
like we'll have all these different
um instances of thing number one
some instances of thing number two
and we can have kind of multiple
multiple relationships going on
at the same time now let's start simple
say we have in our database a users
table actually let's go with students a
student's table
a little bit more specific and in the
students table we have two fields
a student has an ID
and a student has a name
let's say we are thinking about adding a
new entity to our database and this
entity Is a GPA right a grade point
average and we're trying to decide how
we're going to relate a GPA to a student
well once we decide that it's a
one-to-one relationship meaning a GPA
and a student are tightly coupled to one
another right a student has one and only
one GPA and that GPA is related to one
and only one student right if that's the
case then it's pretty simple
we just add a new field right we just
add a new field called GPA
generally speaking with a one-to-one
relationship it's easiest to model that
as just another field on a database
table there is one other option though
what we could do and I would argue this
is typically a little less common
because it's it's a little more complex
but but I've seen it around is that we'd
create a new table and we might call it
something like I don't know
student
credentials or maybe student
scores
and in this second table
we would have essentially the same ID
and the reason we'd have the same ID
is to make sure that this relationship
remains one to one we at the end of the
day we want to make sure that both of
these tables have the exact same number
of Records so that one record in one
table will relate to exactly one rate
record in the other table and we would
typically do this for organizational or
performance reasons right it's that we
want to take
um you know this field here the GPA
field
and move it into a new table and kind of
keep it
um separated physically and logically
from the students table right and it
would give us some flexibility maybe we
have some other data in here like a test
score
that we'd want to add as as another
field on this table so one-to-one
relationships generally speaking it's
just a field on the same database table
but it might be
a kind of one-to-one mapping of primary
Keys between two tables now let's go one
to many now one to many tends to be the
most common type of relationship that
you'll see in web development right
imagine a user and their tweets right
you have one user and that one user can
have zero too many different tweets that
they've authored let's go ahead and
model this out so let's say that users
have an ID
and a name
seems pretty straightforward and then
tweets will need an ID some text
and now is the tricky part we actually
need to model the relationship between
tweets and users so keep in mind a user
can have zero or many tweets
when this is the case the easiest thing
to do is to put a foreign key
ID on
The Entity that is the many so in this
case the tweets should reference the
users so tweets need a user ID
if you think about it it starts to make
sense right in fact let's just jump
right into some examples say that we
have a user number one name Lane
and user number two
id2 name
Allen
and then a new tweet is created id1 says
hello
and let's say Lane tweeted it so it will
be user id1 right it references
Lane over here in the users table
the next tweet
will of course be
id2 because we need all of the IDS in
the tweets table to be unique right
they're the primary key
with the user ID on this one say it's
hey might be user ID too right so Alan
tweeted this Tweet now when we add a
third tweet
yo let's say Lane tweeted this one again
we could just reference Lane again right
so we can have many tweets right in this
case tweet number one and tweet number
three that are related to one user right
user number one which is Lane in this
case so one-to-many relationships
foreign key on the table of the many now
let's talk about many to many this is
the arguably the most the most complex
uh relationship type many to many
um users and tweets don't really make
sense so let's call uh let's change out
the the tweets table
um for something else let's do groups so
let's say that users can organize
themselves within groups and if you
think about it this starts to make sense
right a user can should probably be able
to be a part of many different groups
but a group naturally can have many
different users in it so we've got a
many-to-many relationship
okay let me move these apart just a
little bit
now a group
a group
is going to have slightly different
data
um
a group should probably have a name I
guess that makes sense but just to keep
it a little unique let's say that a
group also has a size like a Max a Max
size
okay
and let's add a couple of groups so we
can still use
Lane and Allen but we'll create a new
group
call it gophers and it has a max size of
20 and we'll create another group
pythonistas
Max size of 30.
okay got a couple groups and actually
just so that they're different let's add
a third group now let's add a third user
that'll be good
so this will be
user number three
name John
okay now how do we model a many-to-many
relationship the problem is we can't use
a foreign key because if we just add a
foreign key to the group we'd be stuck
with a one-to-many relationship we'd
have no way to relate multiple users to
multiple groups we'd only be doing
multiple groups to one user so the
approach typically here
is to create a new table so we actually
have to add a third table here in the
middle
and this is typically called a joining
table and really its only purpose is to
model the relationship between users and
groups and oftentimes you'll see
you'll see the table just called for
example user groups
right very obviously just kind of
mapping the difference or mapping the
relationship between users users groups
right users and groups
what would actually be in this table
well typically there's just two things
in this table
there is
a user ID
and there is a group ID
right so just two foreign Keys make up
this table and typically you'd put a
constraint on this table and say we're
not going to allow
two rows in this table to be identical
let me show you what I mean so let's say
that lane joins the Gophers group
when he does that the way we're going to
indicate that he's joined is by adding a
new row to the joining table that says
user id1 group ID
one let me add some
some spacing there
so user id1 group id1 now let's say that
lane also joins the pythonistas group so
we do User id1 Group id2
now what I was talking about constraints
earlier what I mean is we wouldn't have
a be we wouldn't allow a second row to
be added here that's identical to this
other row because it's fully redundant
it's telling us the exact same thing
right the lane has already joined the
pythony's group so we wouldn't do that
but let's say that Allen
Alan joins pythonistas as well so
Allen's in the pythonistas group right
and maybe John
maybe John
joins the Gophers group
Okay so
notice the many to many relationship
here right lane has now joined both
groups gophers and pythonistas
um but the Gophers group
also has two different users right it
has Lane and it has John so by using a
joining table we're able to accurately
model a many-to-many relationship so
like we just talked about there's
essentially three different relationship
types we need to concern ourselves with
one to many one to one and many to many
the question here is which is an example
of a one-to-one relationship
a University's professors so
the relationship of University to
professors that's not one-to-one there's
one university has many professors
potentially
um and I mean I guess you could even
have like you know professors that work
at multiple schools at the same time
maybe they're part-time right so
can get a little complicated
a father's children again not one-to-one
can have multiple children
a transactions note
that's potentially one-to-one right
I mean it doesn't necessarily have to be
but it but it could be you could
definitely constrain your app and say
every transaction can have us just one
note on it
or a user's transactions
and that doesn't make any sense a user
should be able to have many transactions
so I think the most correct thing here
by far is a transactions note
next question is how would you model the
relationship between a class and its
name
okay so let's take a class like uh CS 50
right Harvard's famous cs50 class
um it can only have one name I don't see
a world in which you would want
multiple names for an individual class
this seems like a field on a row sort of
situation so I'm going to say one to one
let's take a look at this example of a
one-to-many relationship so
um or a couple examples here
a customer's table and an orders table
right each customer should have zero one
or many orders and this is important to
understand when we say one too many what
we really mean is one to potentially
many right zero too many
um it it's it's okay to have a customer
and like they haven't placed any orders
yet that's that that should be a valid
state of the database a user's table and
a transactions table right again a user
should be able to have multiple
transactions let's jump down to the
assignment it says it turns out that
when we originally designed the cash pal
database schema we assumed that users
would only have a single country that
they lived in with digital Nomads
becoming a thing it turns out many users
actually have dual citizenship so
instead of single you instead of a
single users table where each user has a
single country code do the following
remove the country code field from the
users table and create a new table
called countries with four fields
IDE country code name user ID which is a
foreign key to the users table okay that
makes sense right
so with our current database schema
all we can do is give each individual
user right each individual user row can
only have one country code because it's
just a field on the row or a column on
the row that's a problem so we're going
to remove the country code from the
users table and create a new table so
create table and we're going to call it
countries
and it should have four fields or four
columns ID
integer
primary key I'm going to guess
country code
text
name
user ID
integer
but it's not enough just to add the
column user ID we're going to actually
constrain it with a warranty so four and
four is always hard for me to spell
foreign key on the user ID column
references
users table
ID column
okay
this looks better to me and and I hope I
hope as you're looking at this query
it's it's making sense why this works
right we can now add multiple rows to
the countries table
that reference the same user right so
say you have your user record
Lane right with id1 I can now go into
the countries table and add two records
I can add maybe United States and Canada
and have them both reference Lane so
this is a way for us to model the
relationship between one user and their
multiple dual citizenship next we've got
mini relationships and frankly these
ones are kind of the biggest pain in the
butt because it just takes a little bit
more work to model this in your database
I mean to be fair one to one is the
easiest one to minis kind of middle of
the road and many of the many is hardest
and when I say hard I don't mean it's
like super complex and hard to learn I
just mean there's just a little bit more
leg work to do so typically the way that
we model a many-to-many relationship in
an SQL database is by using a joining
table
so a joining table is a special table
that doesn't really have any metadata on
it right so when I say metadata I mean
like all this extra crap right so you've
got the user's ID and that's its primary
key but all this other crap we can just
kind of call that metadata it's data
about the user right but it's not the
identifier of the user so essentially
you could break almost every uh
database schema up into the primary key
and then the metadata so what I'm saying
is a joining table is really just a
table with only identifiers and no extra
metadata and that's because its only job
is to model relationships which is what
IDs do a great job of now I'll show you
an example of a many-to-many table in
just a minute when we get into this
exercise but I also just want to point
out that one thing that makes our
joining tables better is when we use a
unique constraint across two Fields so
for example uh here in this example we
have a product suppliers table
and all it has on the whole table is two
IDs product ID and supplier ID right so
imagine a products table and a suppliers
table and we're trying to model a
many-to-many relationship between the
products and the suppliers
this joining table
has rows in the table with just two
values the product ID and the supplier
ID and all this does is say I have a
relationship between you know product
one and supplier three or product one
and supplier one or supplier one and
product four right I can now model this
many-to-many relationship because I have
a joining table and this unique
constraint just makes sure that I never
try to model the exact same relationship
twice right when I'm doing a
many-to-many relationship and drawing
lines between the two different types of
entities I don't need the exact same
line drawn twice right so you may have
already guessed it but what a row in
this database means is that I've drawn a
line between a product and a supplier so
say we have our product table and our
suppliers table and at present no
products are associated with suppliers
in other words we're essentially saying
that it the suppliers don't carry any of
the products yet but the minute A
supplier decides to carry a product
right and Supply that product we would
add a row in the database with that
product ID and that supplier ID right
and so if we need to check hey does this
supplier offer this product then we can
just go into our joining table and look
up you know all the products where the
supplier ID equals x right and we could
do it the other way around that's that's
the interesting thing about a joining
table it allows you to do it both ways
so jumping into the assignment says we
have another issue with our current user
to Country relationship in the current
schema a user can have many countries
Associated it with it but there are
duplicate records if two users are
associated with the United States we are
creating two countries records it would
be better if each country only had a
single record that way when a country
changes its metadata for example maybe
it renames itself right instead of
United States of America maybe we want
it to be the United States of America
um we only have to update one record
right in the old schema we were storing
one country per user so if we change the
name of a country we'd have to update
every country record for every user we
don't want to do that we don't want to
duplicate data right
so the assignment says use a joining
table to deduplicate Country data remove
the user ID field from the countries
table
okay so we will no longer have this
foreign key here
now the country's table is simply
countries right
create a new table called users
countries
all right
create table
users countries
it should have two Fields country ID and
user ID
entry ID integer
user ID integer
and we want to add
this unique on both columns constraint
country ID and user ID
perfect let's run that
uh oh what did I mess up
what did I mess up here
there's an extra comma there
on that
there we go
I was required to take a database
normalization class during my CS degree
and frankly it was
look here's the deal there's basically
the academic definition of database
normalization and there's how database
normalization actually impacts the apps
you write now in this video I will give
you kind of a high level overview of the
academic definitions of first second
third normal form but really what I want
you to take away from this video is how
database normalization and how certain
strategies can help you reduce data
duplication in your databases and
improve data Integrity basically just
making your web apps easier to work
within and more maintainable so we are
talking about database normalization and
basically what that means is you can
have a database that's architected in a
less or a more normalized way and the
more normalized the the database is the
less data redundancy you'll have so the
less data duplication right and the more
data Integrity you'll have so the more
correct the data will be so generally
speaking normalization good and the
reason for that is you're much less
likely to introduce data related bugs
into your application so there are four
tiers of database normalization there's
first
normal form second normal form third
normal form and voice Cod
normal form named after the guys who
kind of came up with this system okay so
what does that mean well basically the
the most important thing to understand
is that as the levels go down
your database becomes more normalized
and these names for second third normal
form and boys Cod normal form just map
to some rules
right
so for example
first normal form might have
uh one two three rules associated with
it that's not actually how it works so
I'm trying to trying to give an example
second normal form
adheres to
let's say two additional rules and
and all of the rules from first normal
form so five total rules per second
normal form right third normal form
let's say tax on one additional rule
and it adheres to all of the rules from
second and first normal form hopefully
you get where I'm going with here so
third normal form has six total rules
and let's say Boyce Cod normal form tax
on one additional rule
right and then adheres to all of the
previous
rule sets
so as you normalize your database more
and more you'll be kind of moving down
this kind of tier list of normalization
so we talked abstractly about the idea
that all these normal forms have rules
and now let's talk about the actual
rules themselves so first normal form
has two rules
the first rule is every row
must have
a unique
primary key
and rule number two
is that
there can be no nested tables
okay two very simple rules let me show
you what I mean
here is well let's let's draw out a
little database for ourselves
let's say that we have have a table in
the database and the first row let's say
this is a users table we've got first
name Lane last name Wagner
and then age 17.
if in the same table
I have the exact same row Lane Wagner
17.
then this table does not adhere to for
first normal form
first normal form requires that every
row must have a unique primary key which
translated out of kind of academic
database speak literally just means you
cannot have completely duplicate rows
right so the simplest way to escape to
escape uh
you know this like being outside of any
normal form at all would be to just add
an ID column like if we just add IDs
here and we give row number one
id1 and row number two id2 then
we're in first normal form now there is
this second rule right there can be no
nested tables I've never actually ran
into that in production most production
databases don't even allow you to Nest
tables in the first place so you don't
have to worry about it too much but it
really just means you can't you know
take an entire table and shove it into
the cell of another table
um which again hopefully it just makes
sense why you wouldn't want to do that
um but again most databases don't let
you do that anyways moving on to Second
normal form second normal form actually
just has one additional rule so to be in
second neural form your database must
adhere to First normal form and
what additional Rule and that additional
rule is that all columns
that are not art of the primary
e
must
only be dependents
on the entire
primary
not just a part of the primary key
that's kind of word soup so let's look
at an example
we've got our database let's say we have
three columns we've got first name
we're gonna do last name and first
initial so first name last name
and first initial
and then let's populate the database
with some names so we've got
say we've got two lanes
we've got
a lane small
we've got a lane
Brewer
and then let's say that we've got
an allen small
and then the first initial for all of
these would be l
and a
okay
now this table adheres to First normal
form because there's no duplicate rows
right and no nested tables
set it does not however adhere to Second
normal form and in order to understand
why we have to understand what we mean
by primary key so typically when you're
working in a production database the
primary key in a practical sense will
just be an ID column and that ID column
will always have a unique ID for every
Row in the table that makes database
normalization fairly easy right but
we're trying to understand database
normalization in more of an academic
sense when we say primary key what we
mean is just kind of the smallest number
of columns that we can use to uniquely
identify a row so in this case first
name can't be a primary key on its own
because there's two lanes last name
can't be a primary key on its own
because there's two smalls and first
initial can't be a primary key because
there's two l's
but if we say combine first and last
name columns together they are unique
together right there's only one lane
small combination there's only one lane
Brewer combination and there's only one
Allen small so our primary key is going
to be the combination of first and last
name columns so with that definition in
mind let's read the rule again all
columns that are not part of the primary
key so in this case first initial must
only be dependent on the entire primary
key not just a part of it right here's
the problem first initial is entirely
dependent on just the first name column
in other words it's dependent on part of
the primary key not the entire primary
key one way to solve this problem would
be to create a new table
and to move
to move first initial
the first initial column
down here into that second table
and then we would map
first name to first initial and now
you'll see we actually have some
redundancy down here notice that lane
being mapped to L only needs to happen
once right so we could actually remove
a row
cool now we have one table with unique
data and anytime we need a first initial
we can look up the first initial for a
given name in a separate table
this reduces redundancy right we talked
about how normalization reduces data
duplication and data redundancy we now
have less data duplication moving on
we've got third normal form so remember
a database in third normal form follows
all the rules of first and second normal
form but also one additional Rule and
that is that all the columns not in the
primary key
are dependent
only on the primary key
pendant let's bust out an example I'll
use the same examples last time let's
say that we've got
Lane small
actually let's do this
let's do first name
yeah
last name
will do
first
initial
the key difference is that this time
we'll add at the start
an ID column
and we'll even be good database citizens
and give some unique IDs so in this
example the primary key is literally
just the ID the ID column
okay
and then let's add some data so we've
got we need two lanes
lane lane do Allen again
and we'll do small
and we'll do Brewer in the middle
and then here
we've got l
and a
whoo okay now notice this table actually
does adhere to Second normal form
technically right because yes first
initial is completely dependent on first
name but first name is now not part of
the primary key so it does adhere to
Second normal form I'd argue that it's a
pretty stupid academic distinction
really we have the same problem we're
duplicating data so anyways the way we
fix it is essentially identical we can
take this table
create a new one and strip it down to
just the parts we care about in this
case
we don't need last name or ID we would
just
map
first names to First initials
and the way we're going to do that is by
shrinking it down here
we don't need two lanes we just need a
lane in an Allen
and move this column as well again
remove the redundancy
cool now we have all the same data being
represented
why can't I move that there we go
anytime we need the first initial for a
first name we can look it up in this
secondary table right we've we've
reduced some redundancy and we have a
primary ID column again the distinction
between second and third normal forms in
practice as a back-end developer working
on databases
um is it is fairly meaningless the idea
is basically the same so Boyce called
normal form adds one additional rule
that rule is that a column
that is part of the primary key
may not
be dependents
on a column
that is not
art of the primary
a fun historical fact is that Boyce Cod
normal form was actually created later
after the first second and third normal
forms only after realizing that there is
a way for duplicate data to slip into
tables even when a table adheres to all
the rules of third normal form so this
additional rule was added now in order
for voice Cod normal form to actually
matter the database actually has to be
in kind of a weird and specific State
that's why it wasn't really added till
later when people actually found out
that this is potentially a problem
okay so what do I mean let's take a look
at this database uh we have here with
the four columns released year release
date sales and name
the problem here
is that we have multiple possible
primary keys or candidate primary keys
right for example we could just have the
primary key be the name column right
because all of these names are unique
Kiss Me Tender Bloody Mary I want to be
them he got me right they're all unique
additionally a possible primary key
could actually be the combination of the
release year column and the sales column
right if you take a look 2001 100 2001
200 2002 100 2002 200. those are all
actually unique combinations so so that
could be a possible candidate key
additionally just the release date
column could be its own possible
candidate key so again the thing that
sets up this problem for Boyce called
normal form so we have multiple possible
primary Keys now let's say for the sake
of example that we've chosen the
combination of release year and sales
right these two columns release here in
sales as our primary key
now the problem is that release year
this column is fully dependent on the
release date column so we have a column
in the primary key that is dependent on
release date which is a column that is
not part of the primary key right so so
we're breaking Boyce Cod normal form if
you go back and read the text from
second and third normal forms you'll
actually realize that this isn't
strictly forbidden in those definitions
of normal forms so we can fix this the
way we fix this is just by making
release date not dependent
on release year
right we'll just do release date and
we'll just store the month
and the day
in that column
and if we were saying we might change we
might change this to say release
uh
month day or something like that
you get the idea it's worth pointing out
that the distinction between second
third and Boyce Cod normal forms is
mostly an academic exercise in your
day-to-day job as a developer you
shouldn't be worried too much about the
differences between all of the different
normal forms what you should be worried
about is are you duplicating data is
there a way I can restructure my tables
so that when I update something in one
place I don't also need to update it in
another that will keep your database
less duplicated and it will also keep it
more correct because there's less of a
chance of you forgetting to update
multiple copies of the same data so to
recap really the whole purpose of
database normalization is to get data
integrity and to reduce data redundancy
so one great example of data Integrity
is I like to think of a user's age and
their birthday if we store their age in
in a database right like age equals six
that data becomes incorrect with the
passage of time if we don't touch that
data next year it will just be wrong it
will just be out of date right that that
that data does not have integrity right
it becomes incorrect that's a problem
anytime it's easy for your data to
become incorrect or it becomes incorrect
with time
um
you don't have good data Integrity so if
instead you store the birthday
right now that never gets old and we can
always calculate an age from a birthday
when we need it similarly data
redundancy obviously we've talked about
this but we don't want multiple copies
of the same data in a database that can
actually lead to data Integrity problems
right because maybe we update it in one
spot but forget to update it in another
now we have incorrect mismatching data
so the question is to improve data
Integrity data should generally be
stored in a blank form
pre-calculated or Raw
now if we pre-calculate the data
the problem is again it can become out
of date if the underlying raw data
changes so I would argue store the raw
data makes it easier to update you can
always calculate the result later the
only time you ever really want to store
pre-calculated data is for very specific
performance reasons right and like all
things with performance it's not the
first thing you should optimize you
really would still only start to look
into that if your queries were getting
really slow and becoming a problem
pick the best example of data redundancy
each table has an ID field as its
primary key
it's not redundant a user's address is
stored in two different tables yeah that
seems like a problem right now when they
update their address we're gonna have to
update it multiple places by the way
this is like what governments do I don't
know if you've ever been through this
where like you update your address with
the DMV and like they update it but then
like it's not updated on your taxes it's
because like every government agency has
their own database and so it's not all
synced up it's not all in sync this is
the whole problem of data redundancy
right so you don't you don't want that
within your own system
I'm just going to read these other ones
just in case uh two tables can both
contain fields that store booleans not a
problem because as long as they're
different columns that mean different
things uh that that's that's not
necessarily a problem a country table
and a user's table each contained a
field called name
again not really a problem and frankly
the more you work with production
databases the more you'll kind of find
very common patterns amongst the names
of columns almost every table will have
an ID most tables will have a name
column many tables will have a created
at column right so you can see when each
individual row is created there's
there's some common patterns you'll see
and that's definitely not not a problem
so a user address stored in two
different tables is the answer the next
question deals with the normal forms
specifically we can take a look at this
uh you take a look at this diagram I
think it does a good job demonstrating
you know if you're in voicecod normal
form
then you must also be in third normal
form second normal form first normal
form right boys Cardinal reform is the
most normalized uh database first normal
form is kind of the the minimally
normalized database right
okay
um which form has the most duplicate
data uh it's going to be first normal
form
least normalized next is which form
encourages the most accurate and
up-to-date information
that's going to be Boyce Cod normal form
right the most normalized in the context
of normalization a primary key is made
up of blank table columns now I want to
reiterate this because it's really
important to understand in the context
of normalization a primary key is made
up of one to many columns
okay
in the context of SQL databases that's
not always the case it just depends on
the database technology you're using
right some databases might only allow
you to use one column for a primary key
some might allow you to do unique on two
columns and call that a primary key so
like the different Technologies matter
here just understand that when we're
talking about database theory yes a
primary key can be made up of you know
combinations of multiple multiple table
columns all right we've got an
assignment to go along with first normal
form
says we hired an intern at Cash pal and
her first task was designed a new
companies table this table will store
our business clients data unfortunately
she has committed the unforgivable sin
there's no primary key on this table we
could have entire duplicate rows right
so this this table does not even adhere
to First normal form because we can just
have completely duplicate rows big
problem add an ID field it should be an
integer and have a primary key
constraint on it when you're done the
company's table will be in first normal
form cool
this is easy this is straightforward ID
integer
primary key boom
very rare that you won't see ID fields
on tables in production
now we've got an assignment for second
normal form it says another developer on
our team has created a joining table for
the companies to use many-to-many
relationship Unfortunately they did it a
bit weird they included meta information
about companies on the joining table a
good joining table simply has the IDS of
the entities in the relationship right
we already talked about this metadata
doesn't really belong in joining tables
most of the time
um it manages the relationship of
nothing else any information about the
entities and cells belong in their
respective tables move the column that's
out of place to its proper table be sure
to add it as the last column to the
table you add to okay
so
it looks like our joining table is here
users companies I would expect it to
have yeah a user ID and a company ID
yeah Revenue this is a problem right
this is a huge problem for for several
reasons but just I mean just think about
it for a second imagine that you have
multiple records in this table for a
single company which you obviously will
right because one company can have many
users associated with it so you'll have
like seven different records they could
each potentially have their own Revenue
that doesn't make sense right a company
can just have one Revenue number not not
different Revenue it's all the same
company right so this needs to belong on
that individual
company's record
next we've got an assignment for third
normal form so this rollout of business
accounts is really causing some
headaches for our development team the
company's table has been a disaster our
database architect pointed out that the
idea behind the size field is redundant
if a company has more than 100 employees
we consider it large
otherwise we consider it small remove
the size column from the company's table
and alter the select statement to
calculate a size field in the result set
that works the same way okay so
let's see if this is making sense so
we've got a company stable a company has
an ID a company has a name it has a
number of employees and it has a size so
the problem here
is that these two columns are
essentially the same because we can
always calculate a size as we've defined
size right small or large from the
number of employees it's fully dependent
is what we would say in kind of a
normalization theory it is fully
dependent
on the number the num employees column
so let's get rid of that field it's a
dumb field stupid field it's gone
now we need to alter the select
statement because if I run it in its
current form there is no size column but
we still want the size column in the
result set right theoretically we have
someone looking at this report we want
them to be able to add a glance see if
it's a small or a large company
so we'll just add a little calculation
here we'll say select star and
we'll also select iff
remember we learned this we learned this
function a few chapters back
um we're going to do a comparison on if
num
employees
is greater than what 100 it has more
than 100
then we'll consider it large
otherwise we'll consider it small
and we want this to be named size we
want the column in the result set to be
named size let's run that
oh what did I screw up
I iif not iff I was like I was reading
it I was like it's an iff iif that is
honestly really terrible name for a
function very confusing all right iif we
got it
does this look correct ten thousand
large one thousand large four small 12
small this looks good to me right we
cleaned up our table definition but
we're still getting we're still getting
a good report for our stakeholders
all right we've got a quiz about Boyce
Cod normal form
so cast your mind back to the
explanation of voice Cod normal form
remember that it's it's kind of weird
and doesn't frankly come up very often
um at least in the sense that uh the
distinction between third normal form
and voice cogninal form
okay the question is when can a table be
in third normal form but not boycott
normal form
it has multiple possible primary key
combinations and one of the columns in a
possible primary key is dependent on a
column outside of that primary key
that's sounding right that's sounding
right
um when Raymond F Boyce and Edgar F Cod
decree it so from on high close not
quite
the key that depends on another column
that's not a primary key no that's not
bcnf it has multiple possible primary
Keys yep not that one it's going to be
this top one
this next question is just which should
you optimize for first generally
speaking
reducing duplicate data or speed now
this is really just kind of a
a rule of thumb in software engineering
this isn't like a hard and fast fact but
in my opinion
and I hold this opinion fairly strongly
generally speaking you should you should
start with just reducing duplicate data
because you're going to have fewer bugs
in your application that way you'll be
able to move faster as a team you'll be
able to fix bugs ship features refactor
code right do all of the things that you
normally have to do as a developer
you'll be able to do them better if you
don't have to deal with duplicate data
right
if you have speed problems
that can easily be solved or are best
solved by introducing some duplicate
data that's okay it's not like you can
never ever ever have duplicate data
right I mean at the end of the day
caching just is duplicate data right
it's not necessarily a problem but cash
invalidation is hard right so we kind of
stay away from it as long as we can
this next question is when you don't
need a composite key and remember a
composite key is just when you have like
two unique columns together right so in
the example of a joining table we don't
have an ID primary key column
necessarily right we can just do a
composite key on two different columns
right so when you do not need a
composite key what should be the name of
your primary Keys column B I may have
just given away ID is a very
conventional name this isn't again this
is the hard and fast rule it's not like
your application is going to break if
you name the column key or identifier or
skeleton key But like everyone uses ID
just freaking use it
why don't be confusing right it's kind
of like how everyone uses I in Loops
right for I
uh less than zero like there's just a
convention around some things in
programming and if you stick to them
it'll make your life a little bit easier
this question is which is more important
for your career in back-end development
memorizing the exact definitions of
first second third and boyce-cod normal
form or internalizing simple rules of
thumb regarding database normalization
the answer is internalizing the simple
rules of thumb that's going to make you
a much better back-end engineer in my
opinion right you do not need to know
the exact definitions of these of these
normal forms they are useful theoretical
exercises for us to think about
normalization right but these rules of
thumb right things like adding primary
keys to all of our rows right avoiding
duplicate data not storing data that's
completely dependent on other data right
keeping our schema simple those things
are what you're going to really use day
to day and what you need to keep top of
mind trying to hold the full academic
definitions in your head is just going
to be confusing
finally we've gotten to joins now joins
are actually one of the most powerful
features of relational databases in fact
without joins it almost wouldn't even
make sense to worry about all these
different complex relationships between
tables to put it as simply as I can a
join is just a way to query multiple
tables in SQL database at the same time
now the first type of join that we're
going to talk about is called an inner
join it's also kind of the simplest and
the most common type of joint so by
default a join command is an inner join
so if you just use the join keyword in
an SQL statement you'll be doing an
inner join and an inner join returns all
of the records in table a
that have a matching record in table B
so we have two tables right and we'll
get to the syntax of a join here in just
a second but understand that what we're
talking about is we've got some number
of rows in table a and we've got some
number of rows in table B let's say we
have 100 rows in each when we write our
join query
we're trying to get a single result set
back right so if we got all of those
rows back we'd get 200 rows right well
an inner join is just saying
I don't want necessarily all of the rows
I want all of the rows that exist in
both tables right and we typically link
on some sort of ID so you you can see by
this diagram essentially what we're
saying with an inner join is I just want
the set of rows from both tables that
exist in both tables right so let's say
that in table a we have 100 records and
25 of them share some ID some linking
key
with table B it's only those rows that
we're going to return in the result set
let's take a look at an actual example
so
here we've got some SQL says select star
from employees right so employees is in
this case table a
inner join departments in this case
departments is table B
and now we have this new keyword the on
keyword which is used in tandem with a
join
so this is ha this describes how we're
going to join it describes that key
relationship so inner join departments
on employees.departmentid
equals departments dot ID
so in this case we're saying we want all
of the rows
where
on the employees table the department ID
matches a row in the Departments table
with that same ID
does that make sense think about it for
just a second let's jump into the
assignment and hopefully it will start
to make sense um as we go through some
examples so the assignment says our
front-end team is working on a profile
page and would like to display a user's
country name instead of just the
country's two letter code let's start by
writing a simple join between the users
table and countries table we will expand
on this query more in the next exercise
okay so write an inner join between
users and countries so it's going to and
then the next bullet point says return
all fields from both tables okay so
select
star
from
start with the users table is table a so
select star from users
inner join
between users and countries join on the
country code field so inner join the
name of table B countries
on
running at my spacing right this is
embarrassing there we go on
users Dot
country ID no it would be users.country
code let's take a look at the setup code
so we know what we're working with
okay yes the user's table has a country
code so users dot country code equals
let's take a look at the countries table
countries table dot also country code
okay so we're saying give me all the
rows from sorry all the fields
from the users table
interjoin all of the fields and rows
from the countries table
where the country codes match on both
tables okay let's go ahead and run that
and I want to point out something that's
interesting here
you'll see we have some duplicate
column names that's because when we do
select star from users interjoined
countries we're going to get every field
from both tables so first we're getting
all of the fields from table a right ID
name age country code username password
is admin and then all of the fields from
table B right kind of mashed together in
the result set so this feels right to me
I'm going to go ahead and submit that
moving on talk about name spacing on
tables so when we're working with
multiple tables we can specify which
table a field exists on by using the dot
right we use this in the last in the
last example so this kind of follows a
similar pattern to different programming
languages where you'll use this for like
objects right like you might have a
student object and if you want the field
you would do dot name so SQL luckily
uses a very similar syntax right we can
do tablename dot column name in order to
access a column on a specific table in
fact you'll get yelled at if you're
trying to work with two different tables
and you use the name of a column that's
ambiguous in other words it exists on
both tables you you kind of have to tell
SQL like you know I'm using the name
field on the students table not the name
field on the classes table this will
come up a lot when you're using common
class names like ID sorry not common
class names common field names or common
column names like ID or name
so this query Returns the name field
from the students table and the name
field from the classes table yep makes
sense
moving on to the assignment it's says
adjust the query to return the name and
age fields from the users table return
the name field from the countries table
and rename it to country name
sort by the country name in ascending
order all right so let's fix this fix
the select first in fact I'm going to
run this so we can see kind of the data
that we're working with
okay we got we got a bunch of stuff
there
so we're gonna change this star which is
just all fields
to be a little more explicit so
users.name
[Music]
users dot age
at this point it's it's it's probably
good for me to point out a convention
here you'll notice that
it's it's kind of considered best
practice to name tables in the plural
sense so we wouldn't have a user table
we should have a user's table
that's just it's just good convention it
kind of makes sense when you think about
it right the users table holds many
users so you'll see that come up a lot
all right users.name uses dot age return
the name field from the countries table
so countries
dot name as
country name
and then sort by the country name in
ascending order
so
order by
country name
sending
and remember we can use this
column name because we defined it up
here
let's run that see what we get
name age country name this looks good to
me
all right so we talked about how the
inner join is kind of the default join
in fact you don't even have to write
inner join in your SQL queries you can
just write join and it will perform an
inner join left join however is a little
bit different
essentially what left joint says is it
will return every record from table a
regardless of whether or not that record
has a match in table B
right so like we're always getting every
record from table a regardless of the on
clause in the join query right however
table B will still only get rows that do
have a match in table a
okay
all right
small trick you can do to make writing
the SQL query easier is to Define an
alias for each table this is also just
an important thing to understand when
you start working with a lot of SQL
queries that start to get really long
and really verbose you'll see people
Alias table names
typically to make it shorter so like
aliasing the employee's table as e right
um I don't think that's necessarily
a good idea all of the time the only
time I recommend using an alias in order
to shorten a name is if you're doing
like a lot of manual queries and you're
just trying to type faster right like
your bottleneck is your typing speed
when you're writing queries that are
going to be used for a long time like
you're not just kind of running them one
off against a database like say you're
saving them in your code base for your
backend system to run you probably don't
want to Alias your employees table to
just be e that that only serves to make
your code harder to read okay let's hop
into the assignment hopefully this will
help us understand left joins a little
bit better it says the cash flow team
needs a report on all the transactions
each user has made join the users and
transactions table
okay so it looks like what we're going
to want here is a result set that
includes a row for every single user in
cash pal regardless of whether or not
they have a transaction right
be sure to still return user records of
users who have no transactions right so
we want every single user record
right and then we only care about the
transactions
that actually are associated with a user
if there's like orphaned transaction
records which means like they they are
not attached to a user in the users
table like we can just discard them we
don't care about them
okay
so let's jump right into it
select
it says three Fields uh users dot name
uh the sum of transactions.amount
forgot my comma
as some
account of transactions dot ID
as count now the reason I'm doing
transactions.id here and not just star
is because I only want to count the
transactions records not all the user
records right
right okay from users
left join
transactions now why am I doing it this
way right why am I doing users left join
transactions instead of transactions
left join users well the reason is
because I want everything from the users
table so users needs to be table a right
I want every user I don't necessarily
need all the transactions I only need
the transactions that are related to
users on right users where we do our
linking key so users.id equals
transactions transactions
dot user ID
now we're using some aggregations here
right count and sum so we need to tell
SQL how we want to group our rows so we
Group by
users
dot ID
let's run that really quickly and see
what we get
okay first of all does that look like
the right amount of users let's take a
look at our
input data
Al Alvin Albert yeah this that looks
like looks like we got all the users
successfully
and you'll notice we have some missing
data right we have
uh null sums and zero counts
and that's good
because that means
everything's working right we have some
users that don't have any transactions
yet so this is what we'd expect to see
now there was one last constraint that
we forgot to add
up front so let's go ahead and add that
now it says be sure to order the data by
the sum field into sending order so
order by some descending
run that
cool that looks a little more digestible
right having everything sorted nicely
and submit it now it makes sense that if
we have a left join there would also be
a right join but to be honest right join
is pretty dumb like there's really
there's really not a reason to use it
um in fact sqlite doesn't even allow
write joins although some other dialects
of SQL or database Technologies do allow
you to use a right join if you think
about it the the whole idea behind a
right join is kind of redundant instead
of using a right join and ordering
tables A and B where B is the table you
want all the records from
you can just swap the order of the table
names right and use a left join so
that's why I think left sqlite actually
took kind of a good stance on this and
said look we don't need right joins
because just change the The Ordering of
your tables and we'll just kind of force
you to always make the first table the
one you get all of the rows from I think
it makes it easier to think about that
way so
the question says we can retrieve the
same records with a right join and a
left join by
grouping the table by a different field
giving up and drawing Venn diagrams
changing the field on the table changing
the field that the tables are joined on
or flipping the position of the tables
in the join statement it's going to be
flipping the position of the tables
now next we've got a full join and full
joint actually is different but it kind
of does what you expect it just returns
all the rows from both tables now
something I want to point out that I
don't think I've necessarily given
enough attention to is that joins don't
really operate on columns right they
operate on rows so when I was first
learning SQL I kind of got hung up on
joins and I was a little confused
thinking that like this Venn diagram
represented all the fields in table a
and all the fields in table b or all of
the columns and table a in The Columns
of table B that's not what's happening
here we're talking about the rows right
so a full join will just return all of
the rows from both tables and like we've
seen before what it does when there's uh
you know what it does in relationship to
the columns is just that it matches them
all together right you'll get all of the
columns from table a and then all the
columns from table B
um but you can control which columns you
get back just like you Norm normally
would in the select statement right it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the joins so the question here is select
the best scenario to use a full joint
when you need the matching results from
two tables when you need every single
Row from two tables whether or not
they're related when you need all
results from one table and matching
results from another or when you need
all the results from a single table um
it's gonna be this one when you need
every single Row from two tables whether
or not they're related
uh next we've got this little quiz it
says given the tables and the query
which join type produces the result
okay
so we've got this users table here
and a transactions table here
and a result below
okay
so which join type produces the result
well the result
does not have the same number of rows as
either table which means it has to be a
subset
right can't be a left join can't be a
full join because it only has three rows
and the transactions table is the
smaller table with four rows so we're
getting a subset which means this has to
be an inner join
all right we got some different data now
and we're being asked the same question
so now
let's see we've got one two we've got
seven users and four transactions
and in the result set
it looks like we've just duplicated the
user row once
which makes me think let's see
makes me think that we've got we could
potentially have a left join
going on here and actually I should
point this out because when we did our
left join exercise we did a group by
which means uh we kind of you know we
got the exact same number of rows in our
result set as table a
but if you don't do a group by and
aggregate your table B rows
you can from a left join actually get
more rows in your result set than we're
on your left side you're like your left
hand table if that makes sense
um
because you'll get one row per like
related
uh per relationship
so
um
select star from users left join
transactions on user ID equals
transactions.user ID this is the left
join
this is a left join because we don't
have every transaction
right if I check the transactions we've
got one two three transactions
transaction IDs we're missing
transaction id4
so this is a left join now again I just
want to point this out really quickly
here in the results set
we have two records for David and you
might be wondering why because when we
did our left join exercise earlier this
wasn't the case
the reason for that is because David is
the only user here that has two
transactions
right so we get one row back for David
and we get all that data and we get his
essentially his first transaction in
this case the transaction with ID3 and
then we get another row for David
with his data for transaction one and it
this is the default behavior when you
run a join right you get all of the
combinations of the relationships
between the rows and the tables the
reason that we did not get multiple
records for our users earlier was
because we did a group by aggregation
on our table B which we could do here in
order to smash those rows so just just
be aware that's what's going on all
right we got another quiz
new result set
okay this one's looking like it's
actually based on the transactions table
and if we look at the query we've got
select star from users blank
transactions so in this case
could be an inner join
but let's see could it be an inner join
no it's not an inner join because the
last row in the result set does not have
a user associated with it it's not an
inner join it's definitely not a full
joint this is a right join
because transactions is table B down
here in the query
right so we get all the rows from table
B and only the associated rows from
table a
all right time for some joining practice
joints take some time to get used to but
the key to understand and using them
effective is practice that couldn't be
more the truth you just gotta write a
lot of SQL sometimes
okay multiple joints to incorporate data
from more than two tables you can
multiply multiple joins okay so select
star from employees left join
departments on employees Department ID
equals departments.id interjoined
regions on departments.region ID equals
regions.id cool right so we can we can
potentially join lots of tables together
um one thing I will point out I think
we'll talk about this more in the next
chapter is that
um depending on how much data you're
joining together this can be a reason
that queries get slow so you know just
keep that in mind as you're architecting
back-end systems if you're planning on
using a lot of joins for queries that
have to happen say maybe many times per
second you might start to get
um
some slowness in your app
okay assignment says our front-end team
is finalizing the profile page for
cashpal we need to write a query that
returns all the user data they need for
an individual user's profile the query
needs the following fields
okay return only a singer a single user
record specifically the one with ID
equals six okay
how many tables are we working with here
we are working with looks like a user's
table
a countries table and a transactions
okay so select
which are only a single user record so
users
dot star sounds like single user records
simply the one with ID equals sick
uses.star
from users
now we don't want to do some joining
now how do we want to do this joining
oh the query needs to return the
following Fields okay sorry I messed I
missed that up so we used to users.id we
need to do users.name
users.age
.age
users dots
username
users country name rename to country
names it's actually going to be that's
going to be on the countries table so
countries Dot
uh name is my guess as to how that's
named we could probably look here
yeah countries.name okay
and
then we also need the sum of the users
transaction amounts so
but I misspelled users
so sum of transactions dot amount
as balance
okay so that's the data we're selecting
now let's think about our joins
so we know we're going to be filtering
this down just to a single user row
um
so we just want to make sure that we
don't have any duplicate rows right we
want just one row for the user
so
thinking
when we join the countries table
I think we can just do a regular old
join which is I mean it's the same thing
as an inner join right
inner join
countries
what this means is if the user doesn't
have a country we won't return a row for
them
so actually I don't like that
we should probably do a left join here
because we want that we want that user
record either way and if they don't have
a country associated with them we should
probably just leave like we should just
be okay with this column being blank so
let's left join that left join countries
on users Dot
country code equals
countries dot country code
okay now transactions we definitely want
to left join on
again just in case you know the there
are no transactions we want like a
balance of zero for example so left
joint transactions on
transactions Dot
user ID
equals users dot ID
and because we're aggregating the
transactions we'll need to do a group by
so Group by
users dot ID
and that should get us pretty close
let's run that no such column users dot
identity oh my autocomplete is killing
me there we go
okay so this is looking correct we've
got one row per user I think the only
thing we need to do now is filter down
to a specific user so we can just end
this whole thing actually we don't end
because where goes before the group by
um
let me just say where
users dot ID equals
six
right
on that
cool
Alan aliers we've got the country name
ooh do we need to rename country name
yeah that was close I almost missed that
countries.name as
as country name
this is really common right where you
have two names uh two column names that
are identical name and name and so you
want to change the name of one of them
in your result set so that you get
something that makes a little more sense
cool submit it
we're on the home stretch now we're in
the last chapter where we're going to
talk about performance now I've
mentioned this before but really
performance with your database is
actually one of the last things that you
need to think about when you're
designing how you're going to set up
your database right which database
technology you use and how you're going
to architect your schema
performance is important don't get me
wrong but getting the data right having
the data you know reducing data
duplication increasing data Integrity
those things are generally speaking more
important because it'll stop you from
shooting yourself in the foot with bugs
performance is something that you
typically want to optimize for once you
start having performance problems or
once you know that performance problems
are going to start happening in the near
future right maybe you're onboarding
tons of new users every week that's when
you really should start be thinking you
should start thinking about performance
for the first time so at the heart of
performance in SQL databases is the
index
the index SQL indexes and an index is
really just an in-memory structure held
onto by the database that ensures that
queries we run on our database are
performance which just means that they
they run quickly
um if you have taken a data structures
and algorithms course and if you haven't
that's fine I actually have a data
structures and algorithms course on boot
Dev that you can go check out if you if
you are not familiar with DSA but if you
are a binary tree is one of the most
popular data structures and in fact
binary trees are what are typically used
by SQL databases under the hood in order
to create indexes and without going too
far into the weeds a binary tree is
really just
a a tool that we can use to efficiently
find a value in a sorted list of values
so when you think about an ID column on
a database
IDs are sortable right we can sort them
into a list and then by using a binary
tree we could perform a essentially a
binary search on that list and very
efficiently find the value we're looking
for right in other words if we have a
million rows in our database and we do a
lookup by ID on that database table
our database if it's using an index will
not have to scan every Row in the
database to find the row we're looking
for instead it can use the index to very
quickly use that binary tree that binary
sort to find the key it's looking for
and then go directly to that row
so in Big O notation looking up using an
index is a log n lookup rather than an
end time lookup if that just went way
over your head
go check out my data structures and
algorithms course but really the only
thing you need to know is that the index
makes the lookup a lot faster so let's
check out the create index syntax so in
order to create an index on our database
table we just use the create index query
we create an index name technically we
could call it anything but probably a
good idea to make it descriptive on a
table and on a specific column in that
table it's fairly common to name an
index after the column it's created on
with a suffix of idx so for example
email idx if you want to index the email
column so
I I just want to point out like why and
when would you do this right well let's
take the user's table for example
right now we have an index on the ID
column because by default if you specify
a primary key on a column that column
will be indexed automatically
but what if
we are constantly looking up users in
this database by their email and not by
their ID right the ID is the primary key
but but maybe like on the login page for
example the users aren't supplying their
IDs they're just supplying their emails
so we need to do a query and look up the
users by emails well that query is going
to be slow if we don't have an index on
if we don't have an index on that column
right uh it's not going to be slow if we
only have like a thousand records or ten
thousand records but it's going to get
very slow once we have 1 million records
or 10 million records so at that point
it gets really important we need to
think about how we index our columns
so the assignment says here as it turns
out the front end frequently finds
itself in a state where it knows a
user's email but not their ID right this
actually is very common let's add an
index to the email field called email
idx okay
so here we're going to create an index
we're going to call it email
idx
on the users table
column name
email
cool
let's run that
and you can see down here I'm just doing
there we're just doing a little uh
select on the sqlite master uh to get to
make sure that the index was created
properly
all right now it's important to talk
about when we should index things
because you may be thinking to yourself
well if indexes just make everything
fast then let's just add indexes on
every column in the database right
that's actually not a good idea for
several reasons but really
um one of the best reasons is that
actually creating the index does have
some overhead to it so when you create
an index on a column what you're telling
the database to do is to now keep an
in-memory store
of the data in that column right so
rather than just storing it on disk it's
now going to bring it into memory so
indexes have a non-zero memory cost to
create them right even though they make
queries faster when you run the queries
they can actually blow like memory usage
of the database as an example there's
other things too uh for example now when
you insert a row into that table
the binary tree actually has to do an
insert operation which is you know a
little slower than if it didn't have to
do that so if you've got hundreds or
thousands of indexes on a very large
database you might start to see other
kinds of performance problems so as a
general rule
I would argue it's best practice to not
create indexes until you have a good use
case for them right until you need them
to speed up an individual query
so the question here is a binary tree
index makes lookups and this is in Big O
notation order log n order n log n order
N squared or order n
and the answer is that it makes the
lookup's order log n which is extremely
fast
and again I don't want to do like a
crash course on data structures and
algorithms in the middle of this SQL
course but if this is going over your
head please feel free to go check out
my algorithms and data structures
courses on boot.dev
next question says add indexes to blank
all columns only foreign Keys columns
that you frequently perform lookups on
or only primary keys
and the answer is columns that you
frequently perform lookups on right once
you understand that you're doing a lot
of lookups on a column and that those
queries are starting to get slow that's
a good time to go add an index to that
column
it's also worth pointing out by the way
that when I say
doing a lookup on a column I'm talking
about the where Clause I just want to be
specific about that right like for in
the example of the users table it'd be
like select star from users where email
equals x that's a lookup on the email
column so the email column would need an
index right an index on the ID column in
that case does you no good next question
says indexes slow down blank
write speed or read speed
now my assumption here is that when we
say read speed we mean lookup speed
right and they definitely don't slow
down lookups they speed up lookups but
they can slow down rights right now
every time that you insert a row into a
database you need to update all of your
in-memory binary trees in order to keep
them up to date which again makes sense
if you understand how Brian Archies work
um there's essentially you do some
upfront work to make the lookups much
faster down down the line
now we've talked about single column
indexes which are fairly straightforward
but there's also multi-column indexes
and they're useful for exactly why you
might think right it's when you need to
do a lookup based on more than one
column
okay so let's look at the syntax we've
got create index on blank oh sorry
create user or create index index name
on users and then all the columns in the
index right so in this case the first
name column the last name column and the
age column
okay
it's important to understand
column index is sorted by the first
column first right so the order of these
columns or the order of these fields do
matter for performance reasons
a lookup on only the first column in a
multi-column index gets almost all the
performance improvements that it would
get from its own single column index
okay so what do I mean by that right in
the case of this index here
if I just did select star from users
where first name equals Lane
that would be very fast right
it would get basically all of the
performance benefits from from this
multi-column index because I was just
using
first name field
however
if I did a lookup based on just the last
name or just the age so for example
select star from users where last name
equals Wagner
I would not get all that big a bump in
performance improvements because first
the database needs to essentially guess
at the first name or do like a full
table scan right
um so the the order matters here like
first we care about the first name then
the last name then the age so the reason
you would do this is if the query that
you're running your hot query that
started to get slow
is a aware on like all three of these
things right so like select star from
users where first name equals blank and
last name equals blank and age equals
blank or whatever right so that's the
reason by behind why you would use a
multi-column index and just understand
that you could essentially repurpose it
as an index for the First Column so like
you wouldn't need to go add a second
index for just the first name
probably and I just say I add that
probably at the end because technically
SQL is just a query language and under
the hood every database acts a little
bit differently so it's always just
something to keep in mind
okay so the rule of thumb unless you
have specific reasons to do something
special only add multi-column indexes if
you're doing frequent lookups on a
specific combination of columns all
right let's jump into the assignment it
says we frequently need to look up all
of the transactions between two specific
users there's a page on the website that
allows a user to look up all the
payments they've made to a friend by the
friend's name
add an index on the user ID and
recipient ID columns called user ID
recipient ID idx to speed up our app
make sure the user ID is the first
column in the index so that we can also
use this index to speed up our queries
that only care about the user ID okay
so
create
index
we wanted to name it user ID recipient
ID idx
and we're using that on keyword again
right you'll you'll recognize the on
keyword from joins right on which table
uh the users table no transactions tip
I think this could be the transactions
table
yeah transactions table right there on
transactions
and then the field names it says we want
to make sure to use the user ID
column first so that when we just query
based on user ID it's still fast
then the recipient ID
perfect let's run that
looks good to me
all right we had a whole chapter on
normalization now let's talk about d
normalization right so you'll remember
that I mentioned during the
normalization chapter the generally
speaking normalization is a good thing
and you want to normalize your databases
right you want to reduce data
duplication improve data Integrity all
those good things
well it turns out that sometimes all
that normalization does come at a cost
right when you get to certain levels of
scale all that normalization all of
those foreign Keys the linking
relationships the join queries the sub
queries they can start to get slow
because your database technology is
trying to do all of that heavy lifting
for you all of the time right so
sometimes again I I really want to say
sometimes you'll run into issues that
really can only be solved well by
actually denormalizing your database and
what that usually means is introducing
duplicate data
so that you can speed something up right
so
um
the question here is denormalizing a
database can be used to slow down
queries or speed up queries
um and really the answer is to speed up
like that's the only reason you would
ever like denormalize a database like I
don't know why you'd do it to slow down
the queries
the next question is it's smart to start
with a blank database and blanket as
needed for Speed so I would argue it's
smart to start with a normalized
database and only denormalize it as
needed for Speed we haven't really
talked about this yet
but
Why does adding duplicate data
speed up the database or or why can it
speed up the database well the answer
is that when you copy data you
frequently are putting it in a different
format that makes it easier to get at
makes it easier to access right so let's
take the example of like an aggregation
let's say we want to know how many
transactions a user has
right we can write
a join query on the users in the
transactions table and do a count on all
the transactions and return the count of
the transactions and voila right we have
a count
that was a lot of steps just to get the
count of transactions right if we just
store
current number of transactions
separately in say like a table called
transactions count
now our query to get that transactions
is like just one a very simple query
that can be performed very quickly as
like a primary key lookup right like
select star from transactions count
where user ID equals blank right that's
a very fast query there's no aggregation
involved we like essentially
pre-aggregated by keeping that field up
to date
now again
you have a problem when you do this
because it means now like what happens
when you have 10 transactions
in the transactions table but your count
says 11. right you've you've introduced
a potential problem for data Integrity
in your database so this isn't something
you initially want to do however when
your app gets unbearably slow because
every time a user loads a specific page
you're doing some huge aggregation it
can make sense to denormalize to
pre-calculate right just for the sake of
speed
so start with normalize Dem normalize as
needed a blank database is easier to
keep bug free denormalized it's the same
or normalized I would argue a normalized
database is much easier to keep bug free
because it ensures that your data is
more accurate we couldn't have a SQL
course without uh talking about SQL
injection or SQL injection this is like
the most famous kind of security
vulnerability that you can build into
your apps if you're not careful
um this is a fantastic comic by XKCD
feel free to pause it and read it it's
hilarious go look it up online whatever
I love it okay
um but let's talk about why the joke in
this comic works so
let's pretend that we have
this query insert into students
name so we're inserting into the
students table the name column values
and then a question mark so we're going
to insert some Dynamic value into this
table right so imagine we've got some
back-end server that has this query
programmed into it and it's going to
insert a student's name maybe based on
like the form input on the website right
so you can like type in your name click
enter and like save a new student in the
database
if we're allowing our users
to inject any old string into our SQL
query
then we can open ourselves up to some
vulnerabilities so like in this example
if the user is effectively allowed to
put whatever they want in this question
mark here
under normal circumstances we would
expect them to just put their name right
lane Allen whatever
but if instead they put this
disgusting little snippet of text
they can actually you know rewrite the
query a little bit so instead of this
now we have this filled out version with
insert into students name values
Robert
semicolon now remember a semicolon in
SQL terminates the statement
so whatever comes after it is now a new
statement right so in this case what
what this person did was they altered
the sequel
to to now be two statements the first
one inserting a student named Robert but
the second but the second statement just
says drop table students which means
delete the table
right so by allowing our users to put
anything into our SQL queries we can
open ourselves up to this kind of an
attack or someone just someone just
destroys your whole database table so
the answer to this like the way you stop
people from doing this is by sanitizing
your inputs which means you're basically
detecting this kind of crap and not
allowing it to happen
and you might be wondering oh no that
sounds like a big pain in the butt I'm
gonna have to write some really
sophisticated algorithms to stop SQL
injection
no in practice you you will not have to
do that
um because those libraries exist right
so
um for example if you're writing go
the go standard library has a SQL
package that allows you to like do
variable interpolation right putting
Dynamic values into your SQL in a safe
way that protects against SQL injection
and basically any database Library worth
its salt in any programming language is
going to take care of that for you sure
it's worth looking up and making sure
that your database technology does that
for you
but you need to your database library or
your data client does that for you
um but just just just know that you
don't need to be writing it from scratch
you should be finding a tool that does
this for you there's plenty of Open
Source tools that do that the most
common mistakes that developers make uh
you know surrounding SQL injection or I
should say the most common mistake that
developers make is rather than using a
library's ability to do safe
interpolation
developers will just use like normal
string concatenation in whatever
programming language they're using so so
don't do that don't do like normal
string concatenation where you have like
your SQL and just like a raw string and
you're just injecting values into it
manually using whatever like the default
language features are right in
JavaScript it would be template liberals
in go it would be like
fmt.edsprint f in Python it would be F
strings like don't use those
to put Dynamic values into your database
right your database client should have a
built-in way to do it that's SQL
specific so the question here says SQL
injection is best avoided by using a
modern SQL package that handles the
sanitization of user provided values
that is true
next question says what happened in the
comic all right pause the video read the
comic
so the answers are Robert's grades were
all changed to A's every student's
database or every student's data in the
school's database was deleted Robert's
data was deleted or every teacher's data
in the school database was deleted well
if we look at what actually got injected
here right Robert drop table students
it's just dropping this to the students
table so all the students data in that
school's database was deleted